So, Leute, wir sind am Start.
Habe ich heute Qualitätsoptionen?
Ja, ich habe Qualitätsoptionen!
PogChamp!
Pog aus Qualitätsoptionen heute.
Unglaublich, man kann auch die Qualität vom Stream einstellen.
Und es ist auch unglaublich wichtig, dass wenn ich meinen Desktop und meine VM streame,
dass ich dann 1080p at 60fps habe.
Wichtig!
Leute, guckt mal, guckt mal, wie flüssig ich meinen Maus zeige.
Ihr seht ja das.
Und wie flüssig ich Fenster bewegen kann.
Craig Gersom!
Das ist wie live dabei!
In echt!
60fps Fenster.
Jetzt muss man das Ganze mal vollbild angucken in der Vorschau.
Moment, ich stelle es mal auf 1080p.
Oh, das ist gestochen scharf, Leute!
Stimmt's?
Gestochen scharf!
So scharf war das noch nie, das Stream.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Also meine Vorschau sieht wirklich super aus.
Kann man nicht meckern.
Kann man echt nicht meckern.
So, ja, das vor allem bei Workstations, die habe ich mal, irgendwann, die hatten, die
hatten vor, ich glaube vor zwei Jahren oder vor, nee, das müsste vor zwei Jahren gewesen,
oder?
Keine Ahnung.
Die hatten mal so einen Weihnachts-Cell, da hat es glaube ich, wie viel kostet es
denn normalerweise?
Das hat, glaube ich, nur 90 oder so gekostet, vor allem bei Workstations 14, ist das, ist
das 14?
Was kostet denn das normal?
205, genau, das habe ich auch, das hat bei denen auf der Seite, glaube ich, bloß 90
oder so gekostet, habe ich mir gedacht, hey, ich verwende das schon, verwende das schon
so lange vor allem, wir kaufen mal eine neue Version, lol, alter, lol, Software kaufen
in 2k17, lol, wer macht denn sowas?
Ja, was machen wir denn heute?
Dazu muss ich erstmal ein kleines Intro erzählen, was wir heute machen, und gleich dazu sagen,
es ist eine Sache, mit der ich mich selbst nicht großartig auskenne, wir brauchen heute
zumindest, und es ist sehr gut, dass wir die installiert haben, wir brauchen die Linux
VM, die wir uns eingerichtet haben, die Manjaro Linux VM, die wir uns eingerichtet haben von
paar Livestreams, ist schon eine Weile her, weil wir heute quasi, bis auf zum Testen von
unserem Programm, was wir auch mal unter Windows testen müssen, werden wir das hauptsächlich
unter Linux machen, und ich muss auch noch ein paar Vorbereitungen treffen, also wie
gesagt, ich hab selbst nicht so großartige Ahnung, wie das funktioniert heute, und zwar,
ihr wisst ja, ich bin sehr großer JavaScript-Fan, also um nicht zu sagen, ich bin quasi der
größte JavaScript-Fan, den es so überhaupt gibt, und dementsprechend programmiere ich
auch nie in JavaScript, oder selten, wenn es sich irgendwie vermeiden lässt, JavaScript
hat schon ein paar ganz merkwürdige Eigenheiten, aber heute müssen wir wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen JavaScript, wobei eigentlich, ich ändere den Titel nochmal, eigentlich programmieren
wir wahrscheinlich, denke ich mal zumindest, TypeScript und nicht JavaScript, ja, TypeScript,
muss ich gerade mal ändern, weil eigentlich geht es ja heute, Titel mal ändern, TypeScript,
heute, weil, wenn ich die Wahl habe, wenn ich schon was in JavaScript machen muss, ja,
dann kann ich mir die Arbeit ein bisschen einfacher machen, und das ganze wenigsten sind TypeScript
machen, ich werde euch auch gleich erzählen, was wir machen, sobald sich der Titel aktualisiert
hat, weil Twitch ist so eine kleine Indie-Streaming-Seite, da kann man nicht erwarten, dass sich der
Titel innerhalb der ersten drei Minuten aktualisiert, aber ich hab hier wenigstens Qualitätsoptionen
heute, hat sich der Titel letztendlich aktualisiert, eigentlich, Leute, eigentlich sollte der Titel
des Streams jetzt sein, labern über JavaScript, Schrägstrich, TypeScript, kotzen, ist das
bei euch angepasst, ist das bei euch richtig, ja, der Titel ist richtig, nice, okay, also,
was wir heute machen wollen, ist, so, doch, ich hab gerade F5 gedrückt, ist da, guckt
mal, ich zeig's euch, Titel ist aktualisiert, Moment, ich bin hier nicht in Twitch eingeloggt
und Twitch hat trotzdem neues Loot, aha, na, wenn Twitch das meint, beziehungsweise Amazon,
können wir nicht in einer anstellenden Sprache was machen, ich würde gerne, ohne Scheiß,
ich würde das, was ich heute machen will, ich würde es gerne in, keine Ahnung, in C-Sharp,
in C++, in Ruby, in irgendwas außerhalb, unbedingt TypeScript machen, aber, ich glaube,
wir kommen nicht drum herum, und zwar, was ich machen will, ist mir heute auf der Arbeit
aufgefallen, und zwar, ich habe auf der Arbeit mal vor einer Weile was programmiert, das
nennt sich das Lul-Tool, und das ist jetzt kein Witz, das heißt wirklich so, es führen
einige Leute regelmäßig auf der Arbeit in ihrer Shell den Befehl Lul aus, ohne dass
sie wissen, was Lul heißt, weil sie das Tool von mir verwenden, das Lul-Tool, so, und was
das Lul-Tool macht, kann ich auch ganz kurz erklären, das macht ein paar Abfragen, das
macht ein paar HTTP-Abfragen, gegenüber ein paar Services, und sucht sich ein paar Informationen
von allen möglichen Seiten, Quellen zusammen, und zeigt dann daraus in der Shell was an,
unter Linux, das ist ein Tool, das funktioniert nur unter Linux, und es ist in Rust programmiert,
weil ich der Meinung war, als ich das programmiert habe, also schon ein bisschen her, also so
lange ist es nicht, ewig her, keine Ahnung, wie alt, das wird so eineinhalb Jahre alt
sein oder so, und damals habe ich mir gedacht, ich wollte schon immer mal was in Rust machen,
Rust ist das Ding, nein, also nicht das Rust hier, also nicht Unity und nicht Rust, sondern
Rust-Programmiersprache, Rust-RS, so, wo haben die schon eine Seite, so, das Tool findet
man nirgendwo, das gibt es nur bei mir auf der Arbeit, das habe ich für unsere internen
Zwecke programmiert, deswegen kann ich jetzt auch nicht so viel genauer erzählen, was
man macht, aber es sucht sich eben von verschiedenen Seiten Informationen zusammen, und stellt
die dann auf der Shell dar, also zum Beispiel eine Sache, die man sagen kann, ist ja nicht
geheim oder so, man kann damit zum Beispiel erkennen, wo welcher Server steht, jetzt über
die Shell, was ganz praktisch ist, man könnte das in irgendwelchen Webinterfaces oder in
irgendwelchen, wie nennt man das, Inventardatenbanken oder so nachgucken, aber dieses Tool verbindet
sich zu ein paar Seiten, zieht sich die Informationen raus, und dann kannst du die relativ schnell
anzeigen lassen, hey, unser Live-System sowieso, keine Ahnung, welche Domain hat das zur Zeit
und wo steht das, und solche Dinger zeigt das an, ja, es ist eigentlich bloß zur Hilfe
für Leute, die öfters mal auf die Kiste drauf müssen, dass sie das auch von der Shell machen
können, und nicht, und jetzt nicht irgendwie Webinterface rumklicken müssen, das eigentlich
habe ich jetzt hauptsächlich, und die meisten Tools, die ich so bastle, bastle ich hauptsächlich
für mich, und damals habe ich mir gedacht, ich könnte das ja mal in Rust machen, ich
habe jetzt einen Source Code leider nicht da, weil ich mal ausprobieren wollte, wie
dann Rust so ist, Rust ist von Mozilla, die Programmiersprache, die sie sich ausgedacht
haben, extra für Firefox, um dort die Sachen schneller und gleichzeitig sicher zu machen,
Servo ist so diese, die neue Browser-Engine, die irgendwann mal in Mozilla reinkommen soll,
die ist in Rust programmiert, und ist halt viel schneller, paralysiert, und was auch
immer Mozilla da so macht, und ich glaube die neue CSS-Layout-Engine in Firefox ist mittlerweile
auch in Rust programmiert, so und Rust ist wirklich super, ich kann gegen Rust nicht
schlechte Sachen, aber Rust macht keinen Spaß zu programmieren, zum Beispiel, wir gucken
uns mal hier ein paar, gucken ob wir hier ein paar schöne typische Rust Beispiele haben,
ich hoffe jetzt kommt die berühmt, berüchtigte Rust Task Force von Hacker News nicht und
flammt mich, aber Rust finde ich nicht angenehm zu programmieren, da haben wir hier ein paar
schöne Beispiele hier, oh beste Seite, komm her, Ugly Rust, suchen wir mal danach, ne das
ist, das ist über das Spiel, so zumindest ist Rust ziemlich eklig, das macht keinen
Spaß da drin, irgendwas ein bisschen komplizierteres zu programmieren, wenn man sowas wie eine
Browser-Engine machen will, ok, hey, das muss schnell sein, das muss sicher sein,
das muss parallelisierbar sein, aber hier, guck mal, allein schon wenn die Fragen erhöhnen,
will das Rust have such anisontax, jetzt gucken wir uns mal das Beispiel aus dem Beispiel
an, die haben ja kein Beispiel drinnen, ach man, ich muss, ja so was, oh wenn ich sowas
schon sehe, das ist, ich finde Rust ist in der Handhabung nicht schön, die benutzen
schon Rust, ja ja, Flixcoder, Mozilla Quantum Rust, glaub CSS ist schon die CSS-Engine,
ja genau, Stylo, genau, das ist Rust, das ist jetzt mit dem letzten Mozilla gekommen,
guck mal, wenn du schon solche Titel liest, warum macht es Rust einem so schwer, ich brauche
mal ein richtig schönes, richtig ekliges Beispiel, richtig schönes, ekliges Rust Beispiel,
beautiful Rust, oh da bin ich mal gespannt, da gibt es immer Leute, die irgendwas posten,
so und ich finde, ich finde allein schon, also das hier ist jetzt beautiful Rust, das
ist beautiful Rust, ich mach das mal ein bisschen größer, ich finde sogar beautiful Rust sieht
schon abartig hässlich aus und Rust, Rust kürzt gerne Sachen ab, die unsinnig sind
meiner Meinung nach, abzukürzen, vielleicht stehen da die ganzen Mathematik-Cores drauf
und dann haben sie so komische Pfeile drin für Return-Wert, anstatt das hinzuschreiben
und dann gibt es hier noch so zwischendrin irgendwelche kleiner größer Dinger zum, ich
weiß an der Stelle, ich glaube das ist der Typ vom Result und du kannst dir quasi direkt
Funktionen angeben und du musst jede Variable angeben, ob du sie read-only machen willst
oder schreibbar und Rust, ja, also Rust ist schön und ein großer Vorteil von Rust, warum
ich dieses Tool auch damals in Rust programmiert habe ist, die Tools bei Rust dabei, du merkst,
dass die Programmiersprache von Leuten entwickelt wurde, die Wert darauf legen, dass die Werkzeuge
gut sind und bei Rust gibt es Cargo, das ist der Package Manager für Rust, also sprich
damit kann ich Rust Sachen installieren, Rust Libraries installieren zusätzlich, wenn
ich da gerade am basteln bin und man kann damit auch seine Rust-Programme kompiliert
man auch mit Cargo, also Cargo ist quasi Compiler Frontend und Package Manager für Library Manager
in einem, so und man kann, man kann mit Cargo sagen, ich muss es euch jetzt nicht näher
zeigen, aber man kann mit Cargo sagen, hey, kompiliere mir mal mein Rust-Programm, sofern
es keine großartigen super Abhängigkeiten hat, mit denen das nicht geht, aber mein Programm
muss ja bloß ein paar HTTP GETs machen und dann ein bisschen aufbereiten, man kann dann
sagen, hier kompiliere mir das mal, so ähnlich wie mit C++ statisch, allerdings nicht alles
statisch, sondern eben auch nicht gegen die libc-Version vom Betriebssystem, sondern gegen
die special libc-Version, das heißt man kriegt dann mit Rust ein Programm raus, das ist
nachdem man alle Debug-Symbole oder sonst was entfernt hat, ist das Rust-Programm am Ende
von mir, also aus dem Compiler raus kommt es mit 4,5 MB und man muss sagen, das ist komplett
Self-Content, es ist alles drin, 4,5 MB und wenn man die ganzen Debug-Symbole und ganz
das Gedöns entfernt, ist das Programm glaube ich am Ende um den MB groß und das ist natürlich
eine krasse Geschichte und das Beste ist, nachdem man das gegen eine alternative C-Library
linken kann und statisch linken kann, ist das komplett alles in einem, das funktioniert
auf jedem Linux, seit kernel 2.6, irgendwas, das ist natürlich richtig geil, das kann
sich dann jemanden das benutzen mit kopieren und auf jedem x-beliebigen Linux verwenden.
So und jetzt ist mir aufgefallen, dass mein Lul-Tool kaputt ist, das ist mir heute aufgefallen
und zwar, man macht mein Lul-Tool Fehler, also sprich, das zeigt im Prinzip schon das
Richtige an, allerdings nicht unbedingt immer von der richtigen Seite, sprich ich hab da
teilweise falsch oder Ults verwendet, die damals aktuell waren und jetzt nicht mehr
aktuell sind und an sich ist das Source Code auch nicht sonderlich schön, ich hab keinen
Bock mehr da drin was zu machen und ich müsste jetzt eigentlich mein Tool umbauen, dass es
die Leute wieder ordentlich verwenden können.
So und da hatte ich jetzt die Auswahl, entweder, also hab ich mir so überlegt, entweder, weil
ich will ja, ich hab's ja programmiert, dass man das verwendet und das haben sich jetzt
auch viele schon dran gewöhnt, ich find's dann lustig, wenn die Leute in ihrer Konsole
auf der Arbeit eintippen, so nach dem Motto LUL und kriegen dann eine Ausgabe.
Ja und ich hab jetzt die Auswahl gehabt, ich mach's entweder in Rust nochmal oder ich
mach's in einer anderen Programmiersprache und jetzt kommen wir zu dem eigentlichen
Thema heute, ich will es allerdings wieder so haben, ich mach mal mein Linux hier an,
ich will es allerdings wieder so haben, dass man sich einfach eine Datei kopiert, einfach
eine ausführbare Datei kopiert und das einfach tut, ja, dass ich keiner, dass ich keine irgendwie
Demian Pakete bauen muss, irgendwelche Sachen, einfach rüberziehen, ausführen und das Tool
macht die eine Sache, die es machen können soll auf so vielen Betriebssystemen, wie
es irgendwie geht, ohne dass man zusätzlich Sachen installieren muss, Abhängigkeiten
installieren muss oder sonst was, das will ich beibehalten.
So, jetzt hab ich mal geguckt, was es für Möglichkeiten gibt, erste Idee, die ich hatte
ist, machen wir das einfach C++, statisch linken alles und sonst was, das ist nicht
so einfach, wie ich mir das vorgestellt hab oder vielleicht bin ich einfach nur so blöd,
du kannst zwar Sachen statisch linken, allerdings ist das alles nicht so simpel, dass da so
ein komplett self-contained Ding am Ende rauskommt, was vor allem halt auch auf Nilux-Systemen
läuft, die alle möglichen Systeme sein können, ja, Hauptsache es ist ein Nilux, da hab ich
mir gedacht, komm, warum machst du es nicht so, wie das auch Discord macht oder was gibt
es denn da noch, ich geh mal davon aus, Skype wird intern wahrscheinlich mittlerweile
auch, ja, was gibt es dann, wie das Steam macht, wie das Discord macht, wie das Origin,
Gameplay und so, wie die das machen, warum machst du es nicht auch so, ich mein, das
ist auch eine Anwendung, die funktioniert auf nahezu allen Betriebssystemen mit dem
gleichen Code und ihr wisst, ich hab eine unglaubliche Abneigung gegen Electron-Anwendungen,
also quasi das, worauf hier der ganze Krampel meistens basiert, zumindest Discord, weil
alles halt ein Chrome, ein Node.js und alles bundelt und am Ende ist das Programm 140MB
groß und braucht 800MB RAM für ein Fenster, außerdem ist ja meins eine Konsolen-Anwendung,
da fällt so ein GUI-Ding wie Elektrone schon raus, so, dann hab ich mir überlegt, was
können wir dann machen, ich will das in irgendeiner ordentlichen Programmiersprache machen, hab
ich mir gedacht, hey, gucken wir mal, wie ist es denn mit.NET Core, hab ich mir da
mal angeguckt,.NET Core, so,.NET Core hat die Möglichkeit, self-contained Applications
zu bauen, allerdings kommt dann ein Ordner raus und keine einzelne Datei, also sprich,
da müssten die Leute ihren Ordner kopieren, irgendeinen Startscript basteln, ist auch
nicht so schön,.NET Core Anwendungen haben auch ein paar Abhängigkeiten zu irgendwelchen
SSL-Libraries und sonst was, die man nicht wegbekommt, die müssen da sein, dass es
läuft, also wirklich self-contained ist self-contained auch nicht bei.NET Core und.NET Core Anwendungen
wieder irgendwo einpacken geht auch nicht so einfach, weil die standardmäßig erstmal
nur als Build-Targets anbieten, ich glaub, Fedora, Ubuntu, Suse und sowas, also es wär
mal eine bevorzugte Variante gewesen, ja, irgend so eine.NET Core Anwendung, eine ausführbare
Datei zusammengepackt, gut ist, geht auch nicht, so, im Flix-Corder, das kann ich dir jetzt
gerade gar nicht so genau beantworten, aber ich hab mir damals, ich weiß, das ist jetzt
eine bescheuerte Begründung, ja, ließ ich mir schon klar, ähm, ich hatte, es hatte
irgendeinen Grund, warum ich wirklich will, dass das komplett alles in einem ist, ähm,
ach keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht mehr, ich krieg's nicht mehr zusammen, es hat unter
irgendwelchen Umständen nicht ordentlich funktioniert, ja, du kannst das auf unseren Servern teilweise
nicht ausführen, äh, Ausrufezeichen tun, nee, ich mach am Tool heute nichts, wir machen
was anderes, zumindest wie dem auch sei, also vielleicht könnte man es auch einfach mit
C++ machen, das Ganze nicht statisch lingen, so, und zumindest hab ich geguckt, was gibt's
denn da noch so zur Auswahl, also was, was könnte man da machen, und ich hab zwei Sachen
gefunden, das erste ist, ich hätt's auch gern in Ruby gemacht, es gibt sowas nennens
Ruby Packer, das da, damit kann man, das ist genau das, was ich haben will, eigentlich
sowas, ach so, ja, Ashidoro, weil du grad Python schreibst, vielleicht kennst du sowas
für Python, dann können wir das vielleicht auch nochmal ausbringen, das wär auch nochmal
eine Alternative, ähm, ich hab sowas für Ruby gefunden, damit kann man, das ist wohl
auch relativ beliebt hier, man hat 582, relativ aktuell, damit kann man quasi, wenn man eine
Ruby Anwendung hat, das ist das erste, was ich gefunden hab, weil ich geguckt hab, hey,
kann man das nicht mit irgendwas mit Ruby machen, Ruby ist, sagen wir mal nach, C sharp, eigentlich
so meine, meine zweite Lieblingssprache, und damit kann man relativ simpel, so ein self-contained
executable bauen, wo ne Ruby Runtime drinne ist, und halt, im Endeffekt kommt da eine
mit der 3 raus, läuft unter jedem Linux, sollte man denken, allerdings ist jedes Linux, doch
nicht so wirklich jedes Linux, weil ich hab's auf ein paar Systemen ausprobiert, es klappt
nicht auf allen, also bei manchen ist die G-libc Version zu alt, und ansonsten klappt
nicht, ok, das ist natürlich doof, und man kann es nicht cross-compile zu Windows, das
heißt, ich bräuchte ein Windows-System zum entwickeln, also, auch kein Bock, ja, hab
ich mir gedacht, ok, komm, scheiß drauf, guckst du mal, was es für Node.js gibt, ihr
wisst ja, ich bin großer JavaScript-Fan, also hab ich gedacht, komm, scheiß drauf, guckst
du mal, was es für Node.js gibt, und hab dann das hier gefunden, Node.js, package, oder
wie auch immer das heißt, package your Node.js project into an executable, und das ist genau
das, was ich will, das hab ich mit ner mini, mini-test-Version mal ausprobiert, und das
funktioniert, das läuft unter Windows, du kannst es unter, das Gute ist, du kannst
die Anwendung unter Linux erstellen, du kannst komplett Executables raushaumt für Linux,
nahezu jeder Version, ich hab's auf dem CentOS 6 getestet, ja, und wenn was auf dem CentOS
6 funktioniert, da funktioniert's überall, ich hab's auf meinem Manjaro getestet, ich
hab's auf Fedora getestet, ich hab's unter Windows 10 getestet, und das lief einfach,
das hat funktioniert, das find ich schon mal gut, der krasse Unterschied ist, wie gesagt,
mein Rust-Programm, was alles enthält, was man so braucht, ist am Ende irgendwie 2 MB
groß, und das hier ist halt 30 MB, aber auf der anderen Seite hab ich mir danach so überlegt,
komm, wir sind im Jahr 2018, ob jetzt 2 MB oder 30 MB, macht ja nicht so viel aus, zumal
das Programm nur kurz läuft, und du nicht viel RAM brauchst, auch nicht, weil so ein
paar Konsolen-Ausgaben macht, ein paar ATTP-Abfragen, so, und das war's im Prinzip, deswegen hab
ich mir gedacht, ich muss mal heute ausprobieren, wie man ordentlich Sachen unter Linux mit
JavaScript entwickelt, bzw. mit TypeScript, weil wenn schon dann mit TypeScript, sonst
krieg ich Anfälle, und natürlich müssen wir das Programm auch unter so den gängigen
Plattformen testen, also sprich, das erste, was wir jetzt machen ist, das heißt, ich
weiß gar nicht, ob wir großartig zum Programmieren kommen, ich denke mal ein bisschen schon,
wir müssen uns erstmal, ich mach jetzt mal meinen Linux-VM an, das ist übrigens die
gleiche Linux-VM, die wir uns installiert haben vor ein paar Streams, das ist schon
ein Monat her oder so, das ist exakt die gleiche Linux-VM, die wir da schon hatten,
so, und wir müssen jetzt ein paar Sachen machen, also ich möchte das Ding gerne testen unter
Ubuntu, ich will das testen unter einem relativ alten CentOS, und unter, keine Ahnung, was
nehmen wir da sonst noch, irgendwas anderes noch, würde ich gerne testen, und zwar so
simpel, wie es irgendwie geht, das heißt, als erstes, und jetzt machen wir mal ein paar
Hype-Geschichten, weil die Leute stehen ja da aktuell total drauf, die einfachste Variante,
um mal zu testen, so grob, das ersetzt keinen richtigen Test auf eine ordentliche Kiste
oder auf eine ordentliche VM, das erste ist, wir gucken jetzt, wie wir ein paar Container
installieren, und zwar werden wir uns, wir werden uns einen CentOS 6 Container installieren,
wir installieren uns einen Ubuntu-Container, und wir installieren uns einen, was weiß
ich, einen aktuellen Fedora-Container, oder sowas in der Richtung, das heißt, als erstes
muss ich mir jetzt mal, und das habe ich unter Manjaro so noch nicht gemacht, muss ich mir
mal einen Containerfront installieren, und zwar bin ich, seit es bei Ubuntu dabei ist,
ein großer Fan von LXD, das ist jetzt nicht so bekannt wie Docker oder sowas in der Richtung,
hat auch ein bisschen anderes Konzept, ein bisschen andere Philosophie, das heißt, als
erstes installieren wir jetzt uns ein paar Container, auf denen wir dann später unser
Programm testen können, ob das auf allen Linux-Distributionen funktioniert, und danach
kopieren wir es uns einfach auf unsere Windows-Maschine und testen es da, äh, das ist Manjaro Linux,
ja das machen wir, das habe ich vor, und natürlich, zwischendurch, wir machen ja relativ selten
was in Linux, das heißt, wenn wir schon mal dabei sind, können wir uns das Ganze auch
ein bisschen angucken, äh, wenn ihr irgendwie Fragen habt zu irgendwelchen, wie macht man
irgendwelche Sachen im Terminal, oder, äh, wie könnte man das jetzt eleganter machen,
oder was mache ich da, oder, oder ein paar T-Max-Geschichten, wozu benutzt man das Ganze,
irgendwas, fragt einfach, und, ihr könnt uns das angucken, übrigens, hallo, Zeitwärts,
der YouTube ist neu hier, sagt hallo, das ist übrigens ein geiles Feature, gefällt
mir, gefällt mir, gefällt mir, ich muss sagen, normalerweise ist es ja so, irgendwie bin
ich heute voll im Redefluss, normalerweise ist es ja so, wenn irgendwie, äh, was von
der größeren Firma übernommen wird, sowas wie, Amazon kauft Twitch auf, in der Regel
denke ich würde erstmal auch gerade scheißen, jetzt ist es soweit, ab jetzt wird Twitch
scheiße, aber ich muss sagen, Amazon hat Twitch besser gemacht, es gibt wenig Sachen, die
ich kacke finde, was ich getan hat seit der Übernahme, ja, so Sachen wie, dass man das
erste Mal hallo im Chat schreiben kann, das finde ich super, absolut top, kann ich nichts
sagen, ganz im Gegensatz zu dem, was, äh, was Google mit YouTube über die Jahre gemacht
hat, wobei YouTube hat auch schon, gehört auch schon eine Weile zu Google, aber YouTube
ist mittlerweile so zerrissen in, in, in, in sich, ja, also was, was Settings angeht,
du hast fünf Dialoge, wo du rein musst, du hast deine Kanal-Settings, du hast deine,
du hast deine Profil-Settings, du hast deine, du hast deine, deine Kanal-Oberflächen-Settings,
du hast deine Google-Plus-Settings, du hast deine Google-Settings, dein Google-Profil,
das ist so wir, du weißt gar nicht, wo du was gucken musst, und, und ich glaube sogar,
dass es auf YouTube möglich ist, ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert, ne,
ich glaube sogar, dass es auch möglich ist, dass man Moderatoren für Kommentare anlegt,
ich glaube, das geht, aber ich hab's uns verreckend nicht gefunden, und, und mittlerweile
ist es, ich hab mittlerweile so wenig Vertrauen in die, in die Menüs und die, die, die Konfigurierbarkeit
von Google und YouTube, dass ich, ich hab Schiss, ich hab Schiss, irgendwas anzuklicken,
von dem ich nicht genau weiß, was es macht, weil ich Angst hab, es löscht meinen Kanal
oder sowas.
Hey, sogar die, sogar die neue Twitch-Beta finde ich nicht schlecht, installiert man
sich, äh, FrankerFacesZ oder BetterTwitchTV, oder ist das fast, fast so gut wie das Alte,
und ich hab euch ja schonmal die Geschichte erzählt, wo ich die, wo ich mal aus Versehen
auf Disconnect geklickt hab, auf YouTube, also sprich, da gehst du in deine Kanal-Settings
und kannst auf Disconnect klicken, und da ist dann, dann wurde auf einmal mein Google-Plus-Account,
äh, wurde er von meinem YouTube-Account getrennt, das wollte ich gar nicht, und das Schlimme
war, danach konnte ich keine Kommentare mehr schreiben, ich konnte unter meinem eigenen
Video keine Kommentare mehr schreiben, weil ich aus Versehen auf Disconnect gedrückt
hab, so, und danach dachte ich mir, ey, easy ist doch überhaupt kein Ding, connectest du
das einfach wieder, weil ich mein, es wurde dann, es wurde dann der YouTube-Account vom
Google-Plus-Account disconnected, das heißt, ich hatte noch eine Google-Plus-Seite, MaxFPS
und ein YouTube-Channel, MaxFPS, die, die waren ja da, die wurden damals beide zusammen
angelegt, also Google-Plus dazu angelegt, dann hab ich mir gedacht, ok, connectest du
das einfach wieder, dann hab ich auf connect gedrückt, ich hab, ich hab, wie sagt man
das, scheiße, und Wasser geschwitzt, keine Ahnung, ähm, das hat nämlich dann 15 Minuten
gedauert, bis man was gesehen hat, und danach hab ich festgestellt, es funktioniert immer
noch nicht, der hat danach automatisch sich nicht mit MaxFPS-Google-Plus connectet, sondern
sich mit eine neue, eine neue, ähm, Firma-Seite oder wie das hieß bei Google-Plus angelegt
und die damit connectet, dann konnte ich immer nur nicht mehr unter meinen eigenen Videos
Kommentare als MaxFPS schreiben, und dann musste ich das nochmal disconnecten, hab ich wieder,
mir halten mir die Hose geschissen dabei, und ich gedacht hab, wunderbar, was jetzt
passiert, und ich weiß nicht mehr, wie ich es dann hingekriegt hab, ich glaub, danach
hab ich von Hand eingegeben, mit was er es connecten soll, und dann hat er zum Glück
das Richtige ausgewählt, ey, ich war so fertig den Tag danach, weil ich gedacht hab, mein
YouTube-Channel ist jetzt im Arsch, und seitdem, ich klicke nichts mehr an, ich klicke nichts
mehr an in YouTube, kannste vergessen, gut, ähm, da haben wir uns ein paar Fische angeguckt,
ich will jetzt erstmal, ich versuch jetzt mal unter, unter Mancharo-LXD zu installieren,
sagt mir mal bitte, ob die Schriftgröße, ob das so passt, oder ob ich noch ein bisschen
größer stellen soll, sag mir mal, ob die Schriftgröße so passt, passt, ok, das schöne an Mancharo
ist, Mancharo ist ein Archlinux-Abkömmling, das ist eigentlich ein Archlinux mit ein bisschen
schöneren Installer, und die haben ein super Wiki, das heißt, wenn man, nein, nein, nein,
nichts, nicht LXDE, LXD, nicht, nicht zu verwechseln, die haben eigentlich ein super Wiki, so mit
dem Gentoo-Wiki zusammen eigentlich das beste, achso Chat verschieben, ja klar kann ich Chat
verschieben, hab ich vergessen, ähm, sieht man ja gar nichts, soll ich, soll ich das Chat,
soll ich das Chatfenster, soll ich das ausplenden, oder soll ich's verschieben, ja, ich verschiebs
nach rechts, rechts sieht man im Terminal eh kaum was, rechts, rechts wird wahrscheinlich
kaum was sein, probieren wir das mal so aus, ich verschiebs mal rechts, äh, wenn's nervt,
sagt mir Bescheid, dann mach mal das Chatfenster weg, so, und wenn man, wenn man unter Archlinux
sowas machen will, ist, das Arch-Wiki ist das beste, so, aber installieren wir uns jetzt
mal ein Container-Frontend, so, ich guck mal kurz in Chat, ob ich irgendwas übersehen
hab, äh, Flixcoder, ich, übrigens, ich hoffe, ich hab die Frage nach, warum überhaupt Statisch-Linken
irgendwie halbwegs ordentlich beantwortet, ich weiß es nicht mehr, ehrlich gesagt, keine
Ahnung, ich weiß nur noch, ich, ich wollte, ich hab mich damals, das war einer der Gründe,
warum ich es in Rust machen wollte, weil man dort total easy Statisch-Linken kann und es
überall auf jedem nur erdenklichen Linux-System läuft, ich, ich krieg's leider nicht mal
genau zusammen, wobei, wenn ich, wenn ich das dynamisch linke, brauch ich da nicht irgendwie
ne gewisse Mindestversion oder so, wo ich sag, hey, die brauch ich mindestens, oder
so, keine Ahnung, zumindest ist es auch mal schön, mal was anderes auszuprobieren jetzt,
so hab ich doch irgendwas übersehen, äh, Swancharo Linux hab ich schon gesagt, Sub-Button
gibt's immer noch nicht, hab ich immer noch nicht, ich hab immer noch nicht Twitch angeschrieben,
ähm, Google Plus, wann wird das endlich geschlossen, ja, das ist ja quasi um absteigen den Ast,
du musst es glauben, jetzt ist das richtig, ne, ich, ich ja auch, ja, ich weiß es ja selbst
immer, ansonsten, ansonsten vielleicht probier ich das auch noch mal ein bisschen C++ aus,
das wär nämlich die zweite Variante gewesen, jaja klar, Franker Face ist set und bei der
Twitch-TV ist es ein Riesenakt, das anzupassen im Hintergrund, ähm, äh, übrigens, ist,
ist ein Mod am Start, ist, haben, haben wir einen Mod, Mod da, gerade, der Patrick ist
da, aber der ist afk, ja, zumindest das Ausrufezeichen Tool, stimmt nicht, äh, ich muss Ausrufezeichen
Tool mal deaktivieren, äh, das, das geht über den, äh, Nightbot, ja, ja, ich, ich deaktiviere
das jetzt mal, weil, ich programmiere ja gar nicht am Screenshot-Tool heute, egal, ich
muss das nicht deaktivieren, das passt schon, ja, Leute denkt immer noch, ich hab den zweiten
Monitor auf, wenn ich das Gas sehr übertreib, kann ich immer noch bannen, ok, gucken wir
mal, wie man LXD installiert, unter, unter Artstellungs, hab ich noch nie gemacht, ach
so, ja gut, das ist nicht drauf, weil ich nicht install, mein Stream hängt, what, Telekom,
please, äh, Stream geht, ok, ähm, ja, install LXC and LXD Package, stand starts LXD Service,
kein Ding, machen wir mal, machen wir mal, wie viel Platz haben wir eigentlich, ja, passt,
Haha, Lol XD
Ah
Ja nicht LXD, D wollen wir haben
Oh, ich hab meine Team Mark Settings noch nicht hier drinnen
Auf dem Rechner
Grausam, da werd ich mich jetzt wahrscheinlich laufen vertippen
Wo ist es denn? Wie heißt denn das Ding überhaupt?
L, X, D
LXD, da ist es doch
Ja, 53
Das wollen wir installieren
Äh, wisst ihr was? Vorher machen wir mal einen Snapshot
Das ist auch ein riesen Vorteil einfach von VR, du machst einen Snapshot, easy
Easy live
Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie verkacke, kann ich es einfach wieder rückgängig machen
Äh, LXD 2.2.1, äh, ja, das scheint aktuell zu sein
Was, ich soll gucken, dass Go Pass nicht gesetzt ist
Go Pass ist bestimmt nicht gesetzt, ich hab kein Go drauf
Go wäre übrigens auch noch eine Variante dieses Tool zu entwickeln, fällt mir gerade auf
Aber ich bin auch kein großartiger Go Fan
So, installieren wir das jetzt, das war 35, äh, 51
So, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert
Ja, das ist gut, das ist gut
Äh, installiert Go
Übrigens hochsecures Passport bei mir, also falls einer meine VM hexen will
Snapshots, also wie die Windows, Windows Wiederherstellungspunkte, ja fast
Fast
Nur, dass die ordentlich funktioniert
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert, übrigens, ähm
Als Terminal, weil das ist das letzte Mal, wurde ich jetzt ja gefragt
Das hier ist ein GNOME Terminal
Mit dem Base 16 Tomorrow Night 256 Theme
Das wollten das letzte Mal laufen, Leute wissen, deswegen zeig ich das gleich, gleich mal Anfang an
Und der Font ist Hack
Hack in der normalen Variante, Schriftgröße 15
Und hier als, im, also quasi
Im Terminal selbst, da hab ich auch TMAX gestartet
Das ist diese Geschichte, wo ich hier unten zwischen den Tabs wechseln kann
Oder hier so Splits aufmachen kann und so was in der Richtung
Das ist auch immer sehr praktisch
Oh, ich muss mal eine TMAX-Konfig kopieren
Ich ahne Schlimmes
Zumindest mal meine Shotguns wieder
Hex auf Font, ja
So, ähm, und noch eine Sache
Ich hab mir schon mal angeguckt
Äh, TypeScript
Anscheinend ist der beste Editor
Für zum TypeScript programmieren
Tatsächlich Visual Studio Code
Also sprich Microsoft sorgt zumindest dafür, dass sie ihre eigenen Sachen ordentlich unterstützen
Wie heißt die Terminal, wie heißt die so mit Terminal so zu splitten?
Das ist TMAX, das da
Das ist ein Terminal Multi...
Wo schreiben sie es denn hier hin?
Multiplex Terminals, genau
Das ist recht praktisch
Stimmt, stimmt, du hast recht, die Visual Studio Code selbst ist ja auch in TypeScript
Ja, deswegen müssen wir gleich noch Visual Studio installieren
Also, jetzt mal zu den Shortcuts, ne
Das kann am Anfang ein bisschen verwirren
Also, und ich hab hier leider meine TMAX-Konfig auch nicht drauf
Zumindest nicht alles, das haben wir damals nicht fertig eingerichtet
Man kriegt, wenn man
Wenn man Steuerung B drückt, Steuerung B ist der TMAX
Standardmäßig der TMAX Command Mode
Also wenn ich Steuerung B drücke
Und danach C für Create macht er mir ein neues Tab auf
Äh, wenn ich Steuerung B drücke
Und Anführungszeichen macht er mir einen neuen Split
Und sowas in der Richtung
Und du kannst mit Steuerung B, Feiltaste nach oben
Kannst du dann die Sachen durchwechseln
Du kannst, ähm, beispielsweise
Man hat sich jetzt hier mehrere Splits aufgemacht
Und möchte jetzt den Split unten rechts im Fullscreen haben
Sag ich Steuerung B, also sprich TMAX
TMAX Mode ansteuern
Dann sag ich Z, dann geht das in Fullscreen
Z kann ich wieder zurück
Und was, was auch richtig cool ist
Wobei ich da jetzt aus dem Kopf gar nicht genau weiß
Wie man es genau aktiviert, wenn man keinen Shortcut dafür hat
Ähm, Sync
Genau, Synchronize Paints
Da kann ich jetzt, wenn ich
Was?
Muss man noch on hinschreiben oder was?
Wird
Ok, ähm
Jetzt kann ich es euch nicht zeigen
Ich hab da nochmal
Aber guck mal, wenn
Warum ist das Anon Command
Der Auto vervollständigt mir das doch sogar
Wollte das jetzt mal zeigen
Weil im Hintergrund, der ist ja eh noch am installieren hier nebenbei
Äh
Ach, off
Aha
Ok, ok, ok, also muss man
Ups, also muss man
Z
Synchronize Paints on
Muss man machen, genau
So, und ihr seht jetzt
Jetzt schreib ich das gleiche in jedem dieser Splits
Was halt sehr praktisch ist
Man fragt sich jetzt vielleicht erstmal
Wozu brauch ich den Scheiß
Also sprich, warum sollte ich quasi in jedem
In jedem meiner Unterterminal Fenster jetzt exakt das gleiche schreiben wollen
Aber stellt euch mal vor
Hier oben bin ich auf
Ähm
Hier bin ich auf Server 1, hier bin ich auf Server 2, hier auf Server 3 und auf Server 4 eingeloggt
Und ich möchte
Und das sind alle Server, die gleich aufgebaut sind
Und ich möchte mir jetzt irgendwelche Logs anzeigen lassen
Ja
Ähm
Dann, oder mal was einfacher so
Dann kann ich mir das
Dann kann ich mir das quasi
Auf jedem
Auf jedem Server anzeigen lassen
Ohne, dass ich jetzt
Überall das gleiche eintippen muss
Also das ist wirklich unglaublich praktisch
So
Das hab ich mir normalerweise im Shortcut gelegt, weil
Das hier, das hier zu tippen, das ist ja
Kann sich ja keiner merken
So, und ähm
Das mach ich das wieder aus, jetzt kann ich wieder nur in dem Einzelnen tippen
Also das ist wirklich, wirklich eine coole Geschichte
Und, achso, ja, noch mal, noch mal, noch mal was
Brauchen wir ein bisschen abschweifen, aber
Wie gesagt, wir machen so wenig Spätlilogs, können wir das mal machen
Weil angenommen, ich hab mir jetzt, ähm, hier auf
Auf meinen vier Server die Logs angeguckt und gesagt
Ah, guck mal, hier oben sieht irgendwas anders aus
Ich will mir das jetzt mal genauer angucken
Angenommen, ich will mir hier oben jetzt, ähm
Die, die Status-Conf genauer angucken
Wenn ich jetzt natürlich das hier eingebe
Dann mach ich die auf jedem Server auf, das will ich ja nicht
Ja, oder zum Beispiel, ich geb Reboot ein
Das will ich garantiert nicht auf jedem Server machen
Dann kann ich einfach sagen, Steuerung BZ
Ups, Steuerung BZ
Dann mach ich das in Fullscreen, was ich bearbeiten will
Guck mir, guck mir die Datei hier an
Denk mir so, ah, nice, super, Fehler gefunden
Sag ich wieder Steuerung Z
Und, ähm, ich bin wieder auf allen Servern da
Und das hat er nur auf dem einen gemacht
Also, sehr praktisch
Und, also, TMAX wäre ein bisschen was auf der Linux-Kommandozeile macht
Und, ähm, für jeden, ja
Also auch für, ich würd sogar sagen
Selbst für Windows-Desktop-Entwickler
Die normalerweise da nicht so viel mit zu tun haben
Ist ne ordentliche Shell
Ne ordentliche Kommandozeile mit TMAX
Ne gute Sache
Weil es geht ja heute immer mehr davon weg
Dass man einfach reiner Entwickler ist oder rein hat
Selbst ein Entwickler hat mal ein bisschen was mit Sauber zu tun
Und muss sich da besser das hart drauf verbinden und umgedreht
So
So, guck, ihr seht jetzt hier unten ist weitergelaufen mein Installer
Oder mein Installer hier von LXD
Sag ich, ok, jetzt will er, dass ich ab und zu mal sag, ja
Schön bestätigen, alles wunderbar
LXD, äh, was? LXD, allow everyone in LXD to talk to LXD
Ja, das ist so
Ist mir wurscht, das ist ne VM auf einem Desktop
Ist mir doch egal was da
Irgendjemand machen kann
LXD needs, äh, UID, GroupID for Root
So that it can create unprivileged containers
Ich weiß nicht ob ich mir das
Ob ich das machen will
Ich, äh, werd mir das mal kurz zwischensprechen
Falls ich das später nochmal brauche
Das ist ja übrigens auch so ne coole Sache
Ich könnte mir zum Beispiel jetzt hier ein eigenes
Ein eigenes Notiz-Tab aufmachen
Dann würd ich dann einfach, wenn ich mir irgendwas notieren will
Würd ich einfach dann immer drauf zurückgehen
Und es hier reinschreien
Also man kann mit T-marks viel machen
Halt je nachdem was man will
Das schreibt einem halt nichts vor
Ja, Flixcode, das ist wirklich praktisch
Ähm, so, jetzt wollen wir mal gucken
Was man jetzt als nächstes machen muss
LXC check soll ich ausführen
Machen wir
Ah, okay, alles enabled
Dann
Ach ja, und übrigens noch was cooles
Noch was cooles an LXC
Äh, äh, äh, an, sorry
An T-marks
Wenn ich jetzt wieder hier, ich mach mal ein paar
Panels auf
Und ich mach mal ein paar Panels
Ich hab hier jetzt ein paar Kommandos ausgeführt
So, hier oben ein paar Kommandos, da ein paar Kommandos
Äh, hier läuft oben das ASCII-Quarium
Weil's so schön ist
Und
Ich möchte jetzt zurück scrollen
Dann ist das normalerweise immer ein bisschen schwieriger
Vor allem wenn man gesplittete, gesplittete
Views hat
Ich möchte ja nicht überall zurück scrollen
Also ich möchte nicht hier nach oben
Geht gar nicht sehr, aber
Ich möchte ja nicht überall zurück scrollen
Also ich möchte nicht hier nach oben
Geht gar nicht hier nicht nach oben zurück scrollen
Sondern nur hier in diesem Pane drinnen
Und T-marks hat einen eigenen
Äh, Scroll-Buffer
Für jeden dieser, dieser Panels
Das ist, das ist wirklich sehr praktisch
Äh, warte mal kurz, ich bin sofort am Start
So, übrigens die Uhrzeit ist falsch
Fällt mir da gerade auf
So, ähm, hat er jetzt den Krampel installiert
Dem ich jetzt lange hier drum herum gelabert hab
Seba, der Seba, wo ist er?
Ah, wunderbar, endlich ein Mod am Start
Ups
Jetzt hab ich zugemacht, ganz clever
Ja, ich muss mir echt mal meine, meine
T-marks-Config hier draufziehen
Äh, Sebaro, könntest du, falls, falls du das
machen kannst, falls du weißt wie das geht
und du das als Mod machen darfst
Kannst du das Ausrufezeichen Tool grad mal
deaktivieren
Irgendwie denkt man Rechner, es ist Date
20.3.
Äh, 20.3.
Fuck, 20.33
Gott, ich kann ja mal reden
Ok, so, jetzt hat er das installiert
Wir haben ja auch Check gemacht, sieht alles gut aus
Seht ihr, ich kann jetzt hier zurückscrollen
ohne dass ich das Terminal dazu bräuchte
Alles T-marks, Scrollback, Buffer
Das sieht gut aus, alles aktiviert
Und nun
Was soll ich jetzt machen?
Das ist doch kein Ding
LXC Profile Edit Default
Moment
Darf ich das als normaler User überhaupt
Ja, ich wollte es doch grad sagen
Geht doch gar nicht
Danach können wir Container starten
Und dann machen wir uns, wie gesagt, in Ubuntu Container
In CentOS Container
Ah, Start, ja ok, ich soll starten
Also, machen wir mal
Route werden ist nie verkehrt
System CTL, Start, LXD
Bam
Status
LXD, läuft
Nice
Sehr, sehr nice
Normaler User? Nein, darf ich nicht
Haha
Ich darf das nicht als normaler User
Was aber auch ok ist
Was aber auch in Ordnung ist
Ich pack mich einfach in die LXD Group
Test
Bester Username
Oder, komm
Eigentlich
Eigentlich brauch ich das nicht
Ich kann das auch als Route machen
So, jetzt können wir Container starten
LXC List
Es läuft nichts, wer hätte das gedacht
Und jetzt machen wir mal
Jetzt legen wir uns mal ein Ubuntu System an
Hat er sogar hier oben als
Irgendwo geschrieben, so nach dem Motto
Wenn das das erste Mal ist, dass ihr das ausführt, dann
Gebt es doch mal auf
Und es ist damit, mit LXC ist es
Super einfach
Ihr werdet es jetzt gleich sehen, ich bin hier auf meinem Desktop
Manjaro drauf
Und ich leg mir jetzt einfach mal
Ubuntu 16.04 an
Auf der ich dann meine
Ok, was muss ich machen?
Config
Ok
Ich muss anscheinend noch irgendwas ausführen
Auch gut
Es wäre ja auch zu einfach, wenn das einfach funktioniert
Oder Sebaro hat editiert
Sehr nice
Was muss ich denn machen?
Ok, das ist unser Ubuntu Standard
Mich konfiguriert
Keine Ahnung wie das funktioniert
Ok
Wir machen jetzt mal Google
Adminning
Gucken wir mal was er sagt
Gucken wie das funktioniert, was man da machen muss
Ah, Storage Pool List
Gibt keine
Ja gut, wenn es keine Storage Pools gibt, kann auch keine anlegen
Ich will kein ZFS
Ich will einfach nur
Einfach nur Storage Pool anlegen
Ok
Anlegen
Ah, LXD init muss ich machen
Ah, genau, das habe ich ganz vergessen
Ja, genau, da macht er das nämlich alles für ein
Ich wusste doch, dass da noch irgendwas gewesen ist
Do you want to configure a new storage pool?
Yes
Name of new pool
Default, like default, jawoll
Storage backend
BTFS, nein, directory
Wir haben überhaupt kein BTFS drauf
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Ganz ehrlich
Das ist bei mir lokal im Netzwerk
Das ist vollkommen egal
So
Yes, wir machen mal bei allem
Yes, yes
Ok
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt funktioniert das Ganze wahrscheinlich
Launch Ubuntu
Ja, jetzt funktioniert das
So, und das geile an LXD Containern ist
Es ist egal ob man das jetzt mit LXD macht
Mit Endspawn macht oder mit
Meinetwegen sogar mit Docker macht
Wobei die Philosophie in der Docker ein bisschen anders ist
Moin Tommy
K991
Das ist halt super praktisch
Ich bin jetzt auf meiner Desktop
Manjaro VM
Und kann mir jetzt ein Ubuntu installieren
Und da reinwechseln
Alter, was hast du
Was hat er denn
Wo ist dein Problem
LXD, ja
Ja
Bubble, Lehmann
Das ist gut zu wissen
Das wollte ich schon immer mal wissen
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Was möchte er mir mit dieser Fehlermeldung mitteilen?
Muss ich da
Kann das sein, dass ich noch irgendwas zusätzlich angeben muss?
Ich will ja einen Privilege Container starten
Das ist vollkommen ok
Eigentlich wollte ich euch jetzt zeigen wie super simpel das ist
Sich einen Container anzulegen
Das ist vollkommen ok
Eigentlich wollte ich euch zeigen wie super simpel das ist
Sich einen Container anzulegen
Das muss man machen
Das muss man machen, ok
Ok, anscheinend muss ich den Befehl ausführen, den wir uns vorhin notiert haben
Gut, dass wir ihn uns notiert haben
Und das funktioniert natürlich nur mit Route
So, wenn man das richtig macht geht es auch
Was
Hab ich da irgendwie Mist kopiert, kann das sein?
Ja, ich hab Mist kopiert
Das muss weg
So, wunderbar
Und jetzt
Muss ich das jetzt restarten
Ok
Und jetzt hoffe ich mal, dass es funktioniert
Fick dich
Was programmierst du heute?
Ich setze erstmal was auf,
dass ich was programmieren kann
Warum geht das nicht?
Wisst ihr was, wisst ihr was bei allen Problemen hilft?
Prinzipiell bei allen Problemen
Wenn man Probleme hat, Reboot
Reboot geht immer
Wenn man nicht weiß, was man machen soll, wird einfach Reboot
Und alles ist gut
Jetzt geht's
Rebooted funktioniert
Mal gucken
Äh, achso
Service
Hat es nicht gespeichert?
Ah, nee, System ist es ja
Ah
Nervt mich
Was hat er für Probleme?
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Warum geht das nicht?
Das, wisst ihr das?
Ich hab da so einen kleinen Tick, wenn zwar es nicht funktioniert
Ich muss dann immer rauskriegen, was ist das Problem?
Wir könnten ja einfach mit dem anfangen, was wir eigentlich machen wollten
Aber das geht nicht
Das geht nicht
Ich muss dann rauskriegen, was Sache ist
Warum hab, warum hab ich keine
Warum kann ich keine Container starten?
Äh, kann ich machen? Easy
Hehe
OSX Fanboy
Was soll ich mal ändern?
Moment, haben wir doch schon
Haben wir doch schon gemacht
Warum geht das nicht?
Oh, fuck mich das jetzt ab
Genau das, genau das haben wir doch hier drinnen stehen
Nee, haben wir nicht
Haben wir nicht
Da muss doch LXD irgendwie reingeschrieben werden, aus welchen Gründen auch immer
Äh, dann machen wir das doch mal
Nicht, dass ich in der Ahnung hätte davon, was ich hier eigentlich jetzt genau mache
Was war das?
Nicht, dass ich übrigens
Teile kopieren
Y, Y
Brauchen wir öfters mal
So
Und jetzt mal gucken, ob wir das machen
Und jetzt mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert
Restart, nicht reboot, nein nein
Restart, LXD
Launch
Äh, wie man auf OBS die Follow-Sachen einbaut
Nee, das kann ich dir nicht zeigen, weil da sieht man im Zweifelsfall irgendwelche
Ähm
Dings anmeldet, Daten und sowas
Warum geht denn das nicht?
Das regt mich auf
Wisst ihr Leute, ich hab mir jetzt gedacht, wir installieren uns jetzt LXD
Erstellen uns drei Container, easy, funktioniert alles
Warum geht das nicht?
Muss LXD nicht oben in der Config stehen?
Ich glaube, das ist egal
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es einen großen Unterschied macht
Das ärgert mich
Das ärgert mich jetzt
Das ärgert mich jetzt richtig ab
Linux eats schnell was machen ist nie was
Ja, das ist richtig
Moment, ich enable mal den Service
Das ist ja
Das ist ganz fertig
So
Das muss ja sein
Unter Mir Yeah
Dann wird das vielleicht heute kein TypeScript
Programming Stream, sondern eine
Wie kriege ich LXD zum laufen Stream?
Aber es ist auch okay
Wo ist denn das Problem, alter, was geht da nicht?
Ok, mal gucken, mal gucken
Vielleicht hätten wir einfach mal die Wiki Anleitung
das haben wir ja schon gemacht alles easy hat alles wunderbar funktioniert
klappt oh ist das vielleicht das problem
glaube ich glaube nicht dass ist der wird er wird er meckern
hier meckert er herum ok bei dem ist es auch alles missing
das was solv ok da hat es gleiche problem ja ok dass der tue als gleiche
problem wie ich end of that wird es wird gesolvt
was ist latest köln wir haben ach so haben moment was haben wir für den
köln drauf was haben wir was haben wir für köln drauf ich installe ich
installe jetzt den scheiß drauf wir installieren jetzt 15 ach so geht ja
nicht soll ich vielleicht mal gut starten wir installieren den neuesten
linux köln ist überhaupt kein ding zack
was wurde in der letzten stunde schon alles besprochen eigentlich nur was ich
vor hab ich habe ich mir gedacht hält zum testen installieren wir uns mal drei
linux container easy überhaupt kein ding funktioniert das läuft ehrlich
scenisch
ok den threat den book machen wir uns mal den brauche bestimmt noch weil die
haben alle das gleiche problem wie wir
der hat genau das gleiche problem deswegen diese das art des art
linux wiki und so ist wirklich oder art linux wiki ist wirklich praktisch und
auch das forum gucken wir mal was das hier ausgibt bei uns so als welchen als
welchen user füttern das ganze aus installiert ok haben wir wahrscheinlich
das gibt es bei uns gar nicht ok da machen wir noch mal das was die in der
anleitung reingeschrieben haben wir wir sagen nämlich mal dass unser user zu
nxd gruppe gehört jaja
ok jetzt rebooten wir mal und in den in den neuesten köln und zwar in 415
so und jetzt hoffen dass funktioniert plus rng gift energy wenn man
eigentlich loslegen kann was wir machen zwar ohne sudo 100 prozent cpu lasse
schon mal gut ok mein container heißt aus irgendwelchen
können auch immer immer clean merkel ich fände jetzt clean merkel ehrlich
gesagt besser so und nachdem ich jetzt 25 beziehungsweise 30 minuten was
anderes gemacht haben was ich machen will kann ich jetzt noch mal anfangen
im prinzip ist es übelst einfach sich linux systeme mit container zum testen zu
installieren weil jetzt kann ich einfach sagen lxd lxd list erst mal übrigens
bei der gelegenheit wir können den den miss den wir eben konfiguriert haben auch
gerade noch mal rausschmeißen all den brauche wahrscheinlich gar nicht so jetzt
können wir uns anzeigen lassen was haben wir hier für container und wir haben
hier ein ein clean wir haben hier clean merkel am start und da kann man sich
jetzt ziemlich ein man kann jetzt sagen lxd exac auch ich habe die lxd auto
vervollständigung nicht installiert ganz schlimm
ging das so ja und jetzt sind wir im ubuntu system drinne das ist richtig
geil das heißt ich habe jetzt hier meine
anstellungs des top jetzt haben wir in ubuntu am start und wie wie wie wie
man eigentlich noch mal was so also man kann auf jeden fall sagen lxd stop da
macht das aus also das ist quasi so ein bisschen was wie eine vm auch wenn es
auch ich weiß es ist eigentlich keine vm also der gar der sinnvolle container
das können eigentlich keine vm sind
es geht halt super schnell es kostet quasi keine ressourcen so richtig und man
hat ganz viele systeme zum ausprobieren die liet clean clean was das für
kackname kann man das das müssen wir das müssen wir
kann man das nicht umbelernen wahrscheinlich kann man das um und dann
irgendwie normalerweise wie die kammer und wie gibt man da noch mal ein name an
wie gibt man da noch mal ein name an
da hier so fast genau hinten das gibt man einfach hintran an wie wie wie
gibt man wie macht man lxd lxd auto completion für die shell an
das nervt mich nämlich dass ich das nicht drauf hab ich will hier auto auto
complete für die gut zumindest das funktioniert jetzt also wir legen
legen wir setzen ubuntu container an dann legen wir uns einen was was haben die
sonst noch so liebungscontainer haben die sonst noch so zur zur zur auswahl
steht man was die was sie zur auswahl haben
ich glaube die haben die schon ubuntu die haben den fedora und die haben
ich glaube auch in suz und sowas alpin linux haben sie hier ein arschlinux haben
sind cento es haben wir in selenum sind cento s6 so was richtig schön altes und
wenn unser program darauf läuft da kann ich mir sicher sein das funktioniert
einfach die haben mittlerweile sau viel das heißt wenn ich einfach nur testen
will ob meine software darauf ordentlich läuft dann ist es die
einfachste und simpelste variante soll in selenum noch in cento s cento s6 in
selenum uns richtig richtig alles cento s6
warum heißt es nicht cento es ist doch total hängen geblieben dass es nicht
cento es heißt ich meine das einer ist ubuntu warum heißt ubuntu nicht cento
es denn warum cento s6 amd 64 ok muss man das so schreiben das wäre total
beschreit wenn man ubuntu so schreiben muss und das andere so ob ja nicht so
einfach wie man sich das denkt was ist der unterschied zwischen einem
container einer vm einer vm ist quasi ein komplett nachgebauter rechner aus
sicht des betriebssystems in dieser vm also du siehst du siehst nicht die
echte grafikkarte nicht die echte soundkarte gar nichts eigentlich von der
echten hardware ja du kannst paar usb geräte durchreichen das funktioniert
bei einem container ist es was anderes einen container ist eigentlich da ist
nichts drumherum ein container ist im endeffekt einfach nur ein prozess der
wie jeder andere prozess läuft bloß dass ein paar isolier isolations schichten
dazwischen sind im köln
jetzt funktioniert es nein ach fick dich gibt es aber ist das warum ist das so
schwierig warum kann man nicht warum kann man kommandos nicht konsistent machen
er ubuntu 16 04 installiert aber aber aber cento s6 das funktioniert
natürlich nicht das wäre viel zu einfach wenn es kein cento s6 gibt dann
dann zählen wir uns den federer das geht genauso vollkommen wurscht obwohl es
angezeigt wird ne lxd yes yes also das ist so der unterschied würde ich sagen
zwischen so federer installieren wir uns in federer 26 ein bisschen was älteres
federer 26 was sag mal bin ich jetzt bescheuert
ich werde jetzt ubuntu 16 04 guck bäm easy zu installieren
ubuntu darf ich installieren aber
anderes nichts images images not found obwohl wir gerade auf dieser seite drauf
sind obwohl es da steht lasse excelb schreibt ja ja darum nutze ich kann
linux mehr wegen den dauerhaften workarounds und so weiter war nur noch
am rage am ende selbst in ubuntu was ja schon recht nutzerfreunde ist ja
deswegen habe ich keine donation gekriegt kann das sein oder war das war
das der sound ich habe nämlich kein kein tippi stream auf muss mal gucken ja man
muss halt wissen worauf man sich einlässt vor allem desktop bereich
deswegen empfehle ich auch keinem oder will ich überrede ich auch keinen auf
linux irgendwie umzusteigen
donation tatsächlich easy clap vom just math danke fünf euro test easy clap
poggers easy clap ja hab ich den faden verloren ja also ich empfehle es auch
keine oder ich versuche auch nicht die leute zu überreden irgendwie auf linux
umzusteigen linux ist für das was wir hier machen gut als
entwicklungsumgebung als testgeschichten für netzwerk und sonst was ja
in lxd this image server is reachable through images default remote ok also
das heißt jetzt was vor allem warum geht es mit ubuntu mit cento s und und
fedora nicht ok dann dann machen wir das jetzt da machen wir das gleich jetzt
noch mal also setzten wir image image davor ein images
der requested image kundnot be found wollen die mich verarschen ist die
mann hallo da steht doch ok wir suchen uns jetzt mal einfach wie das
funktioniert ich finde es ja witzig ne lxd launch ubuntu easy kein ding lxd
launch fedora lxd launch fails ja ja könnte man könnte man so umschreiben
ich ok ok ah guck mal guck mal so so schreiben es ja also lxd launch cento s
ok das ist total das ist das ist so eine typische sache wo ich mich bei linux
drüber aufregen könnte wisst ihr auf der einen seite jetzt mal das schön
dass man t-marks haben da kann ich euch jetzt zeigen auf der einen seite
ubuntu hier über lxd zu starten einfach lxd launch ubuntu version name kein ding
funktioniert ja um jetzt irgendwas anderes zu starten mit dem gleichen
befehl ja also im prinzip eigentlich kein unterschied außer den namen
auszutauschen nein da muss es images fedora da muss es images cento s slash
7 slash amd 64 sein weil weiß nicht man weiß es nicht warum das so ist und habe
ich euch schon mal die schlimmste mannpage von allen gezeigt
also schon mal die schlimmste mannpage von allen von von allen gezeigt wo
keine sau versteht was damit gemeint ist wo mich fast gefühlt täglich
leute fragen was damit gemeint ist beziehungsweise nicht verstehen was er
genau macht
so jetzt kann ich mir nämlich endlich mal cento s6 darauf installieren jawohl
funktioniert auch gut und jetzt können wir uns nämlich noch easy clap jetzt
installieren wir uns noch ein was wollen wir uns noch installieren noch einen
richtig krass altes altes debian ihr müsst dazu mit dem chat schreiben nein ich
habe euch das noch nicht erzählt weil sonst sonst passt ja meine ganze
überleitung dann ich auf suze oracle
wenn man kurz reflex braucht und ja was gibt noch nicht genug es macht man macht
ein bisschen oracle ok komm wir installieren wir installieren auch noch ein fedora 26 und gut ist so wunderbar also die
ekligste mannpage um jetzt mal wieder zurückzukommen die mit abstand
beschissenste mannpage sind so hilfe seiten wo dann drinne steht wie befehle
funktionieren die meisten davon sind ja auch ganz ganz nützlich ja ich kann mir
zum beispiel die mannpage von mann von von mannpage aufmachen so mannpage
seption und dann kann ich danach irgendwas irgendwas suchen drin und das
funktioniert dann auch die ekligste die unsinnigste mannpage wobei ich glaube
das habe ich euch sogar schon mal gezeigt es geht push also allein schon der
titel irgendjemand fragt sich was macht geht push dann will sein lokales repo irgendwo
hinschieben da machte die mannpage auf und das erste was er liest ist update
remote raft was update remote rafts along with es ist ich kann nicht mehr
sprechen er associated objects was und das hier ist der beste satz
you can make interesting things happen das ist genau das was ich wissen will
wenn ich in dem mannpage reingucke update remote rafts using local rafts
weil sending object objects necessary to complete the given rafts was zum
teufel macht dieser befehl was macht dieser befehl das versteht doch kein
mensch der diese mannpage liest was das macht ja hätten die geschrieben so nach
dem motto du schiebst damit den letzten lokalen stand auf den server dann
hätte man das verstanden das macht sie im endeffekt auch ja aber nein sie
schreiben hier irgendwas wurde erstmal geht studiert haben muss dass du
verstehst was ist was es macht das ist die schlimmste mannpage und die geht die
die geht mannpage ist weil das habe ich fast täglich dass es probleme gibt mit
geht push weil die leute zum beispiel zu faul sind geht push remote und und
pranschname zu schreiben so die meisten leute schreiben geht push und dass die
vollverhalten ist unterschiedlich je nach gett version was geht push macht
echt hängen geblieben ok so jetzt können wir uns noch mal schön angucken
was dieses blitz in t max bringen ich kann jetzt hier zum beispiel sagen
lxc list wir haben jetzt hier einen wir haben jetzt hier laufen in sento essen
fedora und ubuntu da kann ich jetzt sagen lxc exeq fedora bash zum beispiel so
da bin ich hier oben jetzt auf meinem fedora container hier unten machen wir
das gleiche für ubuntu und hier oben machen wir das gleiche noch mal für was
hatten wir da sonst noch in sento essen und dafür sieht man wie praktisch
dieses blitz sind ich habe jetzt im endeffekt hier mal eine drei container
auf und kann damit wunderbar dann gleich testen gut kommen wir jetzt mal zum
eigentlichen was ich eigentlich heute machen wollte und zwar ein bisschen javascript
bzw typescript basteln wir haben ja nur den ersten schritt überhaupt erst
erledigt ich habe mal nachgeguckt mit was man am besten typescript linux
development irgendwie sowas in der richtung habe ich gesucht und da habe
ich herausgefunden dass anscheinend der beste editor mit der also mit der
besten standard mäßigen unterstützung für typescript ist visual studio code
code haben wir gerade nicht drauf deswegen müssen wir es installieren
das ist auch noch ein punkt warum ich artschlinux gerne habe weil der
paket manager für 3d pakete einfach so simpel ist also da dagegen kackt einfach
jamm und und abt und sowas voll ab einfach rausgesucht was wir installieren
wollen visual studio code binaries wir brauchen da keine wollen das nicht
selbst kompilieren oder so leht er runter installierte und ist da und
funktioniert bist du jetzt gerade mit den containers auf deinem server oder in
deiner vm ich verliere den überblick ich bin heute nur auf meiner vm nur
flix kohler das das ist auf französisch heißt das yoghurt jaurt oder wie
immer man wie ich leute die die französisch kennen französisch
woodface achtung das haben wir uns jetzt mal an das haben wir uns jetzt mal von
lsf habt es gehört wartet mal dance game
ja ja ja ja ja ok gut jetzt haben wir auch französisch gelernt
so das ist aber auch was für die allgemeinen bildung italien ja aber ich
bin heute nur lokal bei mir auf der vm unterwegs visual studio code ist immer
noch am runterladen übrigens wie so oft bei meinen
ich habe jetzt was zu essen stehen schon die ganze zeit kommen die ganze kommt
nicht zum futtern bei der gelegenheit fällt mir ein vielleicht sollten wir
mal die uhr richtig stellen weil es ist nicht 20 oder 37 habe ich kann es sein
kein ntp drauf haben deswegen die zeit so falsch läuft ich brauche aber
eigentlich auch kein npt ntp weil weil meine vm meine vm sollte eigentlich
dafür sorgen also vor allem wer sollte eigentlich dafür sorgen dass die zeit
richtig gestellt wird aber wir können ja mal gucken ob wir das installieren
dürfen
wie ist eigentlich der offizielle weg ntp zeiten zu setzen über system die
haben doch bestimmt so bestimmt irgendwas system die time sind die
natürlich selbstverständlich haben wir da was eigenes was sonst
ich setze jetzt ich war das mal über ntp die zeit setzen und gut ist oder
dauernd ist wahnsinnig schnell
so ist jetzt visual studio installiert
ah ja wo ist der studio ist installiert ok cool dann können wir es ja mal
starten würde ich sagen da ist es also visual studio code nicht visual studio
weil das das unterliegen so weit sind wir bei microsoft auch geil einfach mal um
die zeit zu setzen das ist halt so typisch linux um die zeit per ntp zu
setzen und ich bin erst mal erst mal kompilieren wichtig erst mal eine halbe
stunde kompilieren dass ich jetzt gleich meine zeit setzen kann erst mal
kompletten ntp server kompilieren einfach warum auch immer ich meine ich
hätte ja auch mit date einfach die zeit mal von hand auf 20 uhr auf 18 und 9
3 stetzen kann
oh fuck fuck muss noch mal ich habe
set time ntp sind die jetzt da nix ok hox mal ein wenig off topic vorm stream
aber meine windows datenträger verwaltung will eine festplatte nicht
erkennen ok was genau willst du vorwärts captain ziker hast du fragt hast du
deine dot files irgendwo findet deine shell voll nice wir haben hier gar
nichts gemacht großartig das ist das gleiche man jaro was wir von
pass streams zusammen installiert haben ich habe ich habe nichts großartig ich
habe irgendwie so eine so eine teamaxe config drauf kopiert die ich mir ich
glaube die habe ich müsstest du meinem stream nachgucken wo ich die habe ich
glaube irgendwo von github habe ich mir die runter kopiert und das ist im
prinzip die default installation hier von von pretzto dann sieht die shell so
aus wenn man die ich habe mir haben wir haben nichts großartig konfiguriert
de pool ntp.org permission fällt so gucken ob jetzt die uhrzeit setzt ich hoffe
das war der richtige zeit war das der richtige ntp so aber hier die uhrzeit
stimmt so und jetzt können wir ntp ntp date wieder runterschmeißen
perfekt gut haben auch die urzeit gesetzt nachdem aber selbst was zur
urzeit setzen kompiliert haben das wäre auch viel zu simpel gewesen
gut dann würde ich sagen machen wir uns mal einen eigenen ordner oder haben wir
den repos ordner ich habe immer den repos ordner bei mir im kein repos doch
hier repos
warum habe ich eigentlich standardmäßig so bescheuert eingestellt
so ich will nämlich l haben dass es mir listet zwar nicht all und auch nicht
nach new sondern alphabetisch
nämlich viel einfacher so jetzt sieht man nämlich auch die nicht
versteckten ordner nur man sieht man ich habe den repos ordner sind schon ein
paar sachen drinne da ist auch irgendwas vom stream drinne was haben wir das
letzte mal macht tolles kripp.sh krasse skript beste das ist nicht das ist es
glaube ich nicht wert für die nachwelt erhalten zu werden
ach das war unser nach nee das war unser git unser git wir lernen git stream war
das löschen wir den war ich glaube das brauchen wir nicht mehr so aber es war ein neues git repo und nun können wir anfangen
hast du eigentlich kein interesse mein overwatch ich habe kein kein bock auf
overwatch ich habe überlegt ob ich nicht vielleicht immer wieder angehen mal
wieder geben soll nachdem er sie jetzt genervt genervt wurde was wird das am
ende ich will und zwar wie fasse ich es jetzt am besten zusammen ich möchte mit
type script ein programm basteln also nichts großartiges das darf einfach mal
hallo welt oder sowas machen am anfang und dann gucken wie ich das am besten
zusammen packen kann dass da eine einzige ausführbare datei rauskommt die quasi
läuft unter allen lilox versionen unter windows und unter meck da habe ich auf
der arbeit anwendungszweck für gerade ich wollte mal ein bisschen
probieren was es da so für möglichkeiten gibt jetzt ist natürlich die
große preisfrage die ich mir so gerade stelle warum mache ich das eigentlich
bei mir daheim im stream und ich auf der arbeit wo ich geld dafür kriege
warum ich weiß es nicht so genau wahrscheinlich weil es mich auch
interessiert guck mal der nielson ist da so fangen wir mal an also als erstes
haben wir haben wir noch js drauf nein haben wir nicht da müssen wir erst mal
noch js installieren wie ist denn unter
der beliebteste weg unter artilux noch js zu installieren über paket manager
oder oder wollen die lieber dass man ist anderweitig installiert install noch js
package da machen wir das doch mal
und jetzt so da ist es console lock woodface funktioniert npm funktioniert
nicht weil npm irgendwie nicht mehr mit gebundelt ist mit not was haben auch
immer nicht installieren wir npm noch enderbeut so ist das so war ich das ist
noch ist einfach nur ein javascript interpret ja no chance ist soweit ich
weiß die chrome v8 engine aus chrome ausgebaut so im kern der note jscanner
wird wahrscheinlich sagen max so einfach ist es nicht aber was man eine sache die
man heute eindeutig bei meinem stream gesehen hat ist die meisten sachen sind
nicht so einfach wie sie sich an wie sie am anfang aussehen ok easy das ist ja
kein ding so jetzt ist natürlich die frage installier ich type script über
über npm oder type script irgendwie über package management
ich würde sagen wir installieren type script über über package management oder ist
noch nicht drauf na gut npm install ging doch so oder
quatsch jetzt installiert das ja im gleichen gleichen ordner moment das
will ich doch gar nicht wie mache ich denn das ob wir funktionieren das mit
note
npm install type script
nee nee nee ich weiß dass es mit minus g geht aber ich will es nicht mit minus
g installieren minus g installiert nicht nene will ich
nicht mit minus g installiert ja auf dem system ich will es ja nur für meinen
user installieren ist ja was wir installieren ist jetzt mal in meinem
heimatverzeichnis und dann fügen wir das einfach
dann fügen wir einfach mal not not module spin oder wie das heißt
fack wie macht man das am besten minus u geht das mit minus u
ja ich habe so gerade installiert
probieren wir mal aus okay npm install inside home
how to install local packages das ist doch schön da kriegt mal kleine
anleitungen zu
moment ich will das nicht in mein programm verzeichnungs installieren ich
möchte das ich will es will es quasi global für meinen user installieren kann
doch nicht so schwierig sein was hatten was hatten npm für für dinger javascript
camera wo seid ihr dann ihr funktionierten das ich will es nicht
global installieren installieren
ich will es einfach nur installieren bei mir lokal im user
ich meine ich habe eine idee wie man es machen könnte ich könnte über den
not package als könnte könnte not nicht über den paket managen sehen aber das
ist ja bescheuert ja genau
boah das kann ich leider so kompliziert ist ich hab doch vom anderen rechner das
auch so eingestellt dass es im heimatverzeichnis installiert da gibt's
eine glaube ich will ja glaube nicht notes sucht vom aktuellen ordner den
ganzen viel nach oben bis es den notmodels ordner findet das habe ich
irgendwie bei mir anders eingestellt ich weiß dass auf meinem anderen
lindungsrechter installiert er mir das im heimatverzeichnis ohne minus g ja
genau das das kenne ich dass man das man not über den über nvm installiert
nvm ist die folgt eckte er genau genau okay jaja genau ich glaube so habe ich
das habe ich das bei mir anderen rechner auch gemacht
ja das machen wir gleich das tragen wir gleich in die in meine pass ein so und
nu sollte es eigentlich funktionieren install typescript jetzt kann es
probier ich mal minus g install geht das jetzt
ja nice ja ja funktioniert so ist das schön hallo rastler rastia ein rastler
rastler war schon richtig ja aber so funktioniert so funktioniert
und jetzt habe ich hier unter npm glaube ja wunderbar genauso will ich das haben
weil ich habe keinen bock auf meinem system irgendwie da wenn ich einfach
was ausprobieren will um zu sagen
er ist doch komplett himmlisches vorgehen ist aber so ja das denke ich
bin bei javascript auf das mal dass man die sache ein bisschen doof sind
ok dann können wir jetzt hier anfangen ich habe hunger leute habt ihr was
dagegen wenn wenn wir ein wenn ich ein bisschen social eating ja mal eine runde
social eating machen ich habe übelst Hunger ich habe sie direkt neben mir stehen ok ich
habe typescript installiert alles gut das heißt im endeffekt als nächstes kann
ich wahrscheinlich visual studio code starten aber das war mal code kodra ist
das system eigentlich einer vm ich sage dazu nur so viel
kann man visual studio code auch irgendwie überreden im open folder repos stream ok
bäm da sind wir welcome piss dich alle so dann so wie funktioniert das jetzt
richtig also ich gehe mal davon aus wir müssen einfach eine neue datei anlegen
neue datei anlegen wo wir einfach mal reinschreiben die die speichern wir
einfach mal als main punkt wie gesagt leute ich habe ich mache wenig mit
javascript vor allem vor allem server seitlich ja also browser ab und zu aber
server seitlich beziehungsweise ja auf dem rechner selbst relativ wenig
ich habe von javascript und typescript best practice geschichten überhaupt
keine ahnung und ich will ja auch nichts super komplexes machen wir waren jetzt
einfach mal main typescript datei schreibe rein konsole ok es funktioniert
schon mal es ist leise es funktioniert schon mal guckt leute es funktioniert
mal und das ist das geile das ist das geile an an an visual studio und
typescript finde ich ich habe da ich habe vor einer weile da schon mal ein
paar videos drüber geguckt dass sie sich wirklich dass sie es geschafft haben in
diesem ganzen javascript dschungel wo man wo man nie so genau weiß wie wie
ruft man was auf und was genau kommt jetzt eigentlich zurück dass ordentliche
tools gebaut haben mit mit autover vollständigung dass ich weiß was muss
ich hier angeben und so was in der richtung so konsole lock
monka es gucken wir mal ob das ganze funktioniert
das funktioniert ja so schon mal so schon mal nett das ist jetzt ein
typescript das muss jetzt erst mal zu javascript umgewandelt werden was ich
dann ausführen kann weil das ist quasi ein 20 javascript wie geht das jetzt
mit mir geht wie funktioniert das ich habe keine ahnung getting started
visual studio code typescript jetzt bestimmt super artikel die auch für mich
für nubs für mich was das angeht verständlich sind simpels typescript
project using visual studio code das klingt nicht schlecht npm install
timescript das haben wir schon gemacht configuration tsc in it macht man da aber
tsc in it
sprachen die kein semi-kohler am ende haben typescript möchte das wenn ich
mich richtig erinnere ich habe ich habe den auf der letzten bild konferenz vom
ehemaligen c-sharp ober guru und jetzt halb skript ober guru so eine so intro
zu typescript gesehen seitdem dachte ich muss es mal ausprobieren und wie gesagt
habe damit nicht großartig was gemacht und ich wage mich daran zu erinnern sie
sagen dass sie gerne semi-kohler hätten am ende der zeile allerdings es ist
optional und nur in manchen fällen wirklich pflicht
ok tsc in it succesful succesful das ist immer die beste ausgabe da muss ich
gerne mal weiter gucken create source code haben wir schon gemacht
die sind ja fancy hier source code wir haben den besten source code aller
zeiten console log man ks ok wie geht es jetzt weiter und now we want to set up a convenient build process ok press
control shift p control shift p geht menü auf in visual studio count und dann
configure
mögel
ne
die folgt
die folgt bild-tax
Und auch nicht
Das stimmt nicht was da steht die andere die anleitung ist schon wieder outdated
Lul
Ich glaube das funktioniert so wie ich mir das gedacht habe
Viel besser konfiguriert die Funktion
Bildtask
Watch dass der im Hintergrund im Hintergrund schaut ob sich was geändert hat
und dann haut er mir ein JavaScript File raus das ich ausführen kann
Bild
TSC not found
Ah ja natürlich ist TSC not found
Jetzt ist TSC not found
Ja
Easy funktioniert doch
Wir brauchen überhaupt kein Tutorial
Tutorial braucht es für Noobs
So
Und nun haben wir
Eine Main.js Datei die wir ausführen können mit Node
Und was kommt raus?
OneKS
Genau so wie wir das da reingeschrieben haben
So also nur mal so für mich dass ich checke was da jetzt passiert
Ich schreibe jetzt was in Visual Studio Code
Im Hintergrund
Ich schreibe in Visual Studio Code
TypeScript
Im Hintergrund läuft der Type
Der TypeScript Compiler
Und
Kompiliert
Mein TypeScript zu
Einfach
Im JavaScript
Und Node
Führt das JavaScript dann aus
So weit
So weit so gut
Jetzt wäre es natürlich cool wenn ich den Build-Tast
Noch irgendwie überreden könnte das automatisch auszuführen
Weil jedes
Jedes Mal hier rüber switchen bringt es auch mal eine coole Sache
Hier von Tiling, Window Manager
Und wenn man
Sachen mit Tastatur macht
Zum Beispiel
Also mal angenommen ich habe jetzt hier was geändert
Gespeichert, der hat kompiliert was er ja
Hier im Hintergrund macht
Guck und wenn ich hier Mist reinschreibe sagt er mir auch
Code not compile
Kompiliert er das und jetzt will ich
Das ganze ausführen
Jetzt könnte ich mit der Maus hier rüber klicken, aber nee
Ich drücke hier einfach
Linke, linken Pfeil
Eins nach oben für aus, zack
Moin, kurze Frage
Warum
Wie sieht die JavaScript Datei aus
Ich vermute mal
Genauso wie das hier, weil das
Ist eins zu eins auch JavaScript
Okay, nein, use strict
Bisschen streng, streng sind wir heute
Bei Microsoft, Microsoft wird ganz
Streng, wenn man nicht aufpassen
Kommt Bill Gates persönlich vorbei
Oder noch schlimmer Steve Ballmer
Kommt dann vorbei und stellt sich wenn ich aus dem Bett morgens
Aufstehen will, nehme aber mich
Und touch developers
Also muss man aufpassen, heute sind wir
Ganz strikt bei Microsoft
Also ja die Frage
Warum
Weil ich ein
Also ich will
Was basteln
Genau rauskommt, aber
Ich möchte das zusammenpacken zu einem
Executable, wo dann noch eine Datei
Am Ende rauskommt
Was für das automatische
Neustarten des Node.js Prozesses kannst
Du Node Mon benutzen
Oder TS Node
Für das
Direkte ausführen von TypeScript
In Node.js
Also ich hätte gerne, vielleicht
Weißt ja wie man das mit diesen Tools einrichtet
Ich hätte gerne, ich schreibe hier irgendwas
Kompiliere es und erfülle es mir hier aus
Was nehme ich davon dann am besten
Node Mon
Node Mon klingt wie irgendwas was einfach
Ausführt
Was ich ihm angebe
Machen wir mal einen Vorschlag
Oh noch eine Donation
Das Ebaro wieder
10,51
Spiele ich immer noch BDO
So langsam finde ich mich in BDO immer wohler und
Macht auch Spaß
Ich muss mir nur mal die Zeit nehmen mir meine Daily Login Rewards
Anzuschauen was man damit machen kann
Ja ich habe auch noch 3 Millionen Daily
Daily Login Rewards gebaut
Und das beste
Das beste ist ja an BDO ist der Kreisel
Kreid
Warum schreibst du das überhaupt in TypeScript und nicht in JavaScript
Zum Beispiel, dass ich so was hier
Habe
Ordentlich Autovervollständigung, ne Anzeige von
Parametern und sowas, ich hab einfach ne unglaubliche
Abneigung in JavaScript an sich
Und
Deswegen
Ich wollte auch schon seit ner Weile mal
Bisschen was in TypeScript machen
Äh jetzt
Was will er dann im Skype
Oh
Und
Läden
Leute
Während man
Was
So, äh, ich bin wieder am Start.
So, äh, übrigens, noch einmal, äh, was mir gerade einfällt,
äh, mal ein Beispiel, was ich an JavaScript fragwürdig finde.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ein Beispiel, was, äh, was immer gebracht wird in dem Fall.
Ähm, mal angenommen.
Nur mal so, mal zum zeigen, was, was JavaScript für komische Dinger macht.
Also, das hier ist jetzt, äh, eine JavaScript-Konsole, wo ich Zeug ausführen kann.
Wusstet ihr, ich hoffe, ich schreib das jetzt richtig,
oder fragen wir mal anders an den Chat.
Was würdet ihr jetzt erwarten, was hier rauskommt?
Was, was kommt da raus?
Also, ich mein, die Antwort, das ist ja ein Vergleich,
die Antwort kann ja nur True oder False sein.
Was, was meint ihr, was da rauskommt bei JavaScript?
Jetzt nicht raten im Hinblick auf, okay, ich denke, es kommt das raus,
aber es ist JavaScript, es kommt was anderes raus.
So ganz instinktiv, was meint ihr, was da rauskommt?
Ich kann euch sagen, dass True oder False rauskommt.
Eigentlich sollte ein Fehler kommen.
Nein, es funktioniert.
Wir machen hier einen Moment, wir müssen jetzt mal eine Abstimmung machen.
Sorry, Leute.
Oh, da kommt Scheiß drauf.
Also, ich glaub's euch.
Also, ich würde mal sagen, die meisten, die Mehrheit der Leute meint,
da kommt False raus.
Richtig.
Das ist aber auch noch relativ verständlich.
Zumindest, zumindest könnte ich mir das noch erklären.
Das könnte ich mir noch erklären.
Ich könnte sagen, okay, das hier ist ein Bool-Typ, True,
also, das ist ein Bool-Typ, der jetzt auf True gesetzt ist,
und ich gucke, ob der Equal ist einem String,
wo einfach nur die Buchstaben True drinne stehen.
Da kann ich verstehen, dass da False rauskommt.
Das ergibt irgendwie, das ergibt noch Sinn, ja?
Das verstehe ich.
Aber was meint ihr denn, was da rauskommt?
Also, quasi exakter gleiche Vergleich,
bloß dass wir jetzt nicht mehr fragen, ist True gleich True,
sondern ist False gleich True?
Das heißt, es müsste ja von der Logik her jetzt exakt das Gegenteil von dem da oben rauskommen,
weil wir haben ja den Check einfach nur umgedreht.
Also sprich, wenn True gleich True False ist, ist jetzt die Frage,
was ist False gleich, gleich True?
Und ich sage es euch, es ist auch False.
Warum?
JavaScript, warum? Warum ist das False?
Also, beides für sich gesehen könnte ich noch irgendwie verstehen, ja?
Aber beides in Kombination ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ist das jetzt schon Timescript oder JavaScript?
Das ist JavaScript.
Weiß ich nicht, warum ich das nicht verstehe.
Naja, guck mal, hier oben, das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn,
hier oben vergleichst du dieses Ding, also das da mit dem da.
So, es kommt als Ergebnis False raus.
Hier unten machst du genau das Gleiche,
nur dass du die linke Seite änderst von True auf False.
Und da kommt immer noch False raus.
Das ergibt für mich keinen Sinn.
Ja, wenn Bool niemals drin sein kann, ist die Frage,
warum kann man es überhaupt vergleichen?
Da gibt es bestimmt eine super, eine super krasse JavaScript-Erklärung
für, aber ich weiß nicht, wie sie genau ist.
Es ist zumindest in JavaScript viel, viel komplizierter,
als man sich das Ganze so vorstellt.
So, jetzt fangen wir mal an.
Ja, das Problem ist, Rasta, was ich halt bescheuert finde,
ist, du machst ja, du machst ja den Vergleich.
Du sagst, es kann ja bei einem Equal-Vergleich,
das kann ja nur rauskommen, Ja oder Nein.
Das heißt, wenn irgendwo Nein rauskommt
und ich drehe die Bedingungen dann links um,
von irgendeinem Boolwert, dann muss, von der Logik her,
im umgedrehten Fall, muss True rauskommen.
So bescheuert es jetzt eigentlich in dem Fall auch sein mag,
sonst ergibt es ja an sich überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Es ist aber halt nur ein JavaScript, so wo das Sinn ergibt.
Wahrscheinlich ist es wirklich so, dass er sagt,
die Typen sind nicht gleich.
Allerdings, das stimmt ja auch nicht,
weil unter der Haube führt er das garantiert nicht
mit einem Bool-Typ und einem String-Typ durch,
das ist JavaScript.
JavaScript-Zeug.
Übrigens, ich habe es, ich habe jetzt gerade nachgeguckt,
das habe ich mal in, das habe ich mal in,
in irgendeinem Vortrag, in irgendeiner Präsentation gesehen,
noch, noch was, noch was schönes, was in JavaScript,
was in JavaScript merkwürdig ist, fällt mir gerade ein.
Da muss ich aber nachgucken, wie ging das?
Das muss ich mal kurz raussuchen, wie das ging.
Das war ganz, ganz mir.
Da habe ich aber kaputt gelacht bei.
Wie ging das nochmal?
Das war so richtig, richtig bescheuert.
Wie ging das?
Das muss ich mal kurz raussuchen.
Genau.
Ich glaube, das hier war es.
Ach so, übrigens,
das ist auch geil.
True plus true, was kommt da raus?
JavaScript, überleg mal.
True plus true, true plus true.
Was ist das in JavaScript?
True plus true ist four, das wissen wir ja,
aber was ist true plus true?
Also auf Chat.
Leute, nicht nachgucken.
Es ist zwei, ganz klar.
Was sonst?
Warte mal, das andere müssen wir uns noch kurz angucken.
Ich finde das gerade nicht.
Wo ist es denn gewesen?
Ich glaube, das ist zwei, ganz klar.
Was ist das denn?
Ach so, ich hab's gefunden, noch besser, noch besser, noch mehr quickmust, was kommt hier
raus?
Achtung!
Darf ich das copypasten?
Nee, darf ich nicht copypasten, also, das ist ja geil, true plus true mal, mal true
plus true, also, dass man das, dass das ein gültiger Ausdruck ist, ist ja schon schlimm,
minus true, drei, was sonst, easy, drei, easy clap, so auch kein Ding, ich mein, binär
ergibt das irgendwie Sinn, ja, also quasi, zwei mal zwei ist vier, minus true plus true,
ne, vier, minus drei, minus eins ist drei, aber warum ist das erlaubt, das ist einfach
so?
So, und ich hab übrigens das andere gefunden, was ich euch noch zeigen wollte, wo wir gerade
bei JavaScript bashing sind, genau, pass int, pass int, das ist dafür gedacht, dass man
ein string zu, zu nummern passen kann, also, also zum Beispiel hier, 32 ergibt 32, ne,
also, insofern, klar, so, 32 fuck is not a number, soweit, soweit sind wir uns einig,
oder?
Chat, we koo, we koo, also, können wir uns auf dieses Ergebnis einigen, dass pass int
string 32, 32, also pass int fuck is not a number, ok, aber jetzt kommt das beste,
wisst ihr was, not a number equals not a number is, jetzt, jetzt kommen die JavaScript Profis
raus, nach all dem, was ich bisher gesehen hab, würd ich sagen, das ist true, also nach
allen Logiken, würd ich sagen, das, das, das ist, das ist true, weil ich mein, links
ist der gleiche Ausdruck wie rechts, und nach der Logik her, würd ich jetzt, nach dem,
was wir vorher gesehen haben, würd ich sagen, ok, es ist true, aber es ist false, ich mein,
es hätte auch 32 sein können, das wär genauso logisch gewesen, nur, eh, wisst ihr, nur
mal so als Beispiel, warum ich kein großer JavaScript-Fan bin, ich glaub dir das, ich
glaub dir das, wenn man sich damit auskennt, ja, und sich das im Detail mal alles angeguckt
hat, man kann da bestimmt durchsteigen, aber es ist nicht sonderlich intuitiv, und das
ist das, was mich an JavaScript, JavaScript nervt, das, ja, das Batman Beispiel kenn ich
auch, das ist auch geil, das kenn ich, das, das, das machen wir gleich nochmal, weil es
einer ins Chat geschrieben hat, das Beispiel ist auch geil, ich dafür bring's aus dem
Chat nix, copy paste, deswegen muss ich das jetzt nochmal tippen, RA16Join, das muss man
auch, das muss man auch korrekt immer schreiben, sonst klappt's nämlich immer, das ist ein
Nährzeichen davor, Batman, das ist das beste Beispiel, das hab ich auch mal in einem Stream
gesehen, das ist aber echt geil, das hab ich mal in irgendeiner Präsentation gesehen,
ok, nur aber, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, ich muss was essen, ich muss was essen, ok,
was wollte ich eigentlich jetzt noch machen, genau, das, ich wollte das ausprobieren, was
ich eigentlich vorhatte, und zwar unser wahnsinnig hochkomplexes Console-Log-Monkeys in ein eigenes
Programm verpacken, aber vorher machen wir das, unser Monkeys-Programm noch ein bisschen,
ein bisschen schöner, und zwar gucken wir mal, wie wir Konsolenfarben, nojs, console-colors,
ihr Konsolenfarben machen, ok, es gibt was, das nennt sich Colors, das klingt schon mal
gut, ja genau, sowas wollen wir machen, sowas ist top, npm install colors, minus g, das
ist natürlich wahr, colors, easy, so, wie macht man das jetzt, moment, wie macht man
das in typescript, fuck, wie macht man das in typescript, wie, wie, wie include ich
Sachen, import, ok, namespaces and modules, import, import, import, import, und dann require,
oder was, also sag ich so quasi, import, colors, gleich, require, ah, ah ja, colors, finde
ich, umfinde da das nicht, finde da nicht, ich habs aber noch installiert, wo ist das
also ich meine note selbst findet es ja noch nicht mal
warum javascript kenner warum findet warum findet mein note das modul nicht
machen was mal so jetzt findet erst
weil es voll ist jetzt hatte jetzt hatte hier noch ein module ordner
ach der sucht da gar nicht drin oder wie ja klar dass der sucht ja in meinem npm npm
glaube sucht er ja überhaupt nicht drinne ja ja es logisch der der sucht ja überhaupt
nicht in diesem ordner nach nach modulen
ok das ok passt leuchtet ein der sucht nur in nicht versteckten ortern die
not modules heißen das ist gut habe ich jetzt installiert gut ist ok aber
findet immer noch nicht allerdings allerdings mein mein not findet es doch
jetzt oder mein not findet not findet import import kann was was was war
ist verkehrt was import xy from x
restart ja restart hilft bestimmt
ich kann da gar nichts aus dem chat also was import colors
ja ja was denn sternchen geht so was
kommt auf ein module colors
macht die titel jetzt mal zu mit auf lull
ach ja fack jetzt muss er hier nochmal starten
jetzt erkennt das ok was auch immer darum gespackt hat aber jetzt erkennt
das und jetzt merkt er
ok er findet jetzt alles klar
ich muss jetzt allerdings type definition installieren und das kann ich ja wohl
einfach damit machen
finde das jetzt was hat er denn für schmerzen
kann ich sein dass ich
kann ich sein dass ich da jedes mal in die tonal starten muss oder das kann
auch nicht den uns weg da
ach nee moment ich ich das ist falsch was da mache ich das jetzt noch mal so
wie es an ursprünglich gemacht habe colors gleich require ist ja allein schon
eine wissenschaft für sich was ja funktioniert sehr schön hat funktioniert
so aber wie schreiben die dann eigentlich mal typescript die man das
macht ja der macht es genauso wahrscheinlich gibt es dann wieder 20
varianten das zu machen ich meine es ist ja unter der haufe immer noch ja was
ja gebe ich dir recht so michi gu warum warum ist das so kompliziert sein
ich glaube meine notes setting sind nicht die besten so mit dass im heimat
verzeichnet ist liegt sonst was hast du den stay hydrated bot aktiviert nein was
ist das
den stay hydrated bot habe ich nicht aktiviert das ist wahrscheinlich bot
darum rumsbemt irgendwo und nervt
ja ja ich habe es gesehen nenei habe ich nicht aktiviert da geht
wahrscheinlich einfach mal in channels rein und spamt
so ist das jetzt visual studio code sieht fast aus wie praxis ja das ist
visual studio code so wie verwendet man dieses colors ding jetzt eigentlich
colors ok das ist einfach oder so ja das ist das ist simpel also sage ich dir
sowas wie colors punkt das ist halt das geile an times amerika kennt ihr eine
farbe die amerika heißt also ich mein schwarz blue zyran green magenta red
white sagt mir alles was aber was zum teufel ist die farbe amerika das
probieren wir aus colors bolt amerika bin ich mal gespannt was dafür eine
ausgabe kommt hatte das jetzt kompiliert
soll ich den bann solange das nur einmal schreibt ist mir das recht ok ach ja
sorry falls ich es vorhin überlesen habe irgendjemand hat hat hat hat was
geschrieben wie man das immer das automatisch ausführen kann die
nordprogramme das habe ich nicht gesehen
wahrscheinlich ist derjenige auch weg weil ich jetzt erst mal so krass über
javascript die ganze zeit abgeflemmt
also falls falls er hier noch da ist wirklich mal interessieren wie das jetzt
genau funktioniert hat funktionieren würde mit automatisch ausführen ok
gucken wir mal wie amerika aussieht nach mit noten genau also meinte noten
sollt werden mehr in punkt gs
das falsch gemacht muss ich muss ich so muss ich nur amerika machen
Machen wir mal nur so
BÄM!
Amerikaschrift
Was ist das Schwarz denn?
Kann ich wenigstens so sagen? Bold? So rum jetzt?
Geht das?
Das ist ja hässlich, wie kann ich denn das Bold machen?
Bold funktioniert? Wie kann ich denn Bold
und eine Farbe zusammen machen?
Das muss doch funktionieren.
Das muss doch gehen. Ich muss doch sagen können, Bold
guck mal, macht ihr hier noch auch. Bold und in Grün. Zum Beispiel.
Ok
Bold
Punkt
Green
Geht doch. Ok, warum geht das mit Amerika nicht?
Es verbuckt
Ich würd mal sagen, es ist verbuckt. Guck mal
Green
Easy Clap
Amerika
Kaputt
Weil
Wahrscheinlich weil JavaScript oder so
Es funktioniert. Amerika ist verbuckt. Es geht mit Bold nicht.
Bold und Amerika zusammen. Nope
Aber Amerika alleine funktioniert. Da bin ich ja froh
Ok, das probier ich jetzt mal aus. Also
Also, du installierst NoteMon über NPM
und dann führst du statt
NoteScripner NoteMonScripner mal aus. Ok, gut, das ist ja einfach
Hat das jetzt so schnell installiert oder was? Ach nee, ich hab Install vergessen.
Lass uns das mal ausprobieren.
Jetzt sag ich einfach NoteMon
Main.js
Das ist ja richtig nice. Übrigens, wir müssen mal unsere
unsere Anordnung ein bisschen optimieren
So, ist das besser? Das Termin hier unten machen wir auch mal weg.
So, jetzt sehen wir nämlich ein bisschen mehr
So, hallo
Oh nice, das funktioniert. Das ist schick. Das ist echt sehr, sehr schick.
Ich kann das, theoretisch könnte man den Scheiß hier auch mal auspletten.
Ehe keiner
Oh, das ist nice. Das gefällt mir gut.
Das hat jetzt schon fast schon funktioniert.
Das hat jetzt schon fast schon Visual Studio Komfort
Wobei, das ist voll durch die Brust ins Auge, muss man sich jetzt mal überlegen.
Hier oben läuft im Hintergrund ein TypeScript Demon, der dann
mein TypeScript zu Note.js übersetzt.
Hier unten läuft ein File System Watcher, der guckt, ob Main.js
aus dem TypeScript Compiler wieder neu ausgekotzt wird,
um dann festzustellen, es hat sich geändert und muss jetzt
wieder neu ausgeführt werden.
Passt zu JavaScript.
So, America.
Bolt, Bolt, Red.
Bam, funktioniert.
Nice, sehr nice, sehr nice.
So, und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich würde jetzt gerne
mal einen HTTP, das will ich nämlich noch ausprobieren.
Wir machen zwei Sachen. Also, wir importieren ein Modul.
Wir geben irgendwas Doofes auf der Kommandozeile aus
in America Color, weil es geht.
Feature finde ich irgendwie witzig.
Und jetzt, weil das brauche ich für mein Tool,
jetzt probieren wir mal ein HTTP Get zu machen.
Ich habe noch nie in Note.js
ein HTTP Get gemacht.
Moin, Papa, KXLive.
Ist guter Name.
Also, Fetzen SQL, ich muss sagen, das Setup hier gefällt mir
richtig gut jetzt, ja.
Das finde ich sehr, sehr nice.
Nice, nicer, nicer.
So.
Note.js HTTP Get.
Kann ja nicht so schwierig sein.
Ich meine, Note.js, das ist ja
geboren worden für HTTP Zeugs.
Wie macht man hier ein Get?
Get Header, nein, Response.
HTTP Get.
What?
Moment.
Okay, das ist nur ein Beispiel.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, es kann doch nicht sein,
dass ich das hier machen muss,
um eine Webseite abzurufen.
Beziehungsweise ein Get.
Was machen die da überhaupt?
Was, was, was passiert da eigentlich?
HTTP Get, das ist die Uhr.
Das verstehe ich noch soweit.
Wir machen genau das Gleiche hier jetzt.
Genau, das rufen wir jetzt mal ab
test-wise, unser Programm.
HTTP Get.
Note.js, OK.
Okay, das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Genau, das rufen wir jetzt mal ab test-wise, unser Programm.
Okay, probieren wir das mal aus.
Also, wahrscheinlich müssen wir dann sagen,
import HTTP gleich require HTTP.
Geht nicht.
Doch funktioniert.
Fuck, wie blende ich jetzt die Konsole wieder ein?
Nope.
Da ist das Terminal wieder.
Kann man das nicht links?
Ja, so, da, da ist gut.
Da will ich das andocken.
Was?
Das ist Standardlib, das ist eingebaut.
Oh Gott, Java-Script, ey.
Require HTTP.
Geht, kein Ding.
Could not find module HTTP.
Ja.
Warum nicht?
Okay.
Google.
Oops.
Could not find module HTTP.
Warum kann man kein Standard?
NPM install types node.
Wir machen...
Das ist das wahre Stackoverflow-driven Programming,
was wir hier betreiben.
Repos.
Stream.
Da wollen wir hin.
NPM install types node.
Ja, und das ist auch das Schöne an so einem Tiling-Window-Manager.
Windows-Taste F, Vollbild.
So, mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Could not find module HTTP.
Warum erkennt er die Scheiße denn nicht?
Ich wette mit euch, wenn ich den Editor neu starte,
ist alles gut, es funktioniert wieder.
100%.
Das muss ich noch mal ein bisschen überarbeiten.
Das ist nervig.
Ja, jetzt funktioniert's.
Lol.
Gerade ist das beknackt.
Okay.
Was wird gerade programmiert?
Ich versuche mich an TypeScript.
Und...
Also, erstens habe ich ja nicht großartig Ahnung von.
Und zweitens versuche ich jetzt mal
einen HTTP-Get zu machen.
Und nachdem ich es geschafft habe,
einen HTTP-Get zu machen,
dann möchte ich daraus
eine Anwendung bauen
komplett in einer Datei.
Also, komplett self-contained.
Und...
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich
auch was in NodeShares mache.
Mal ausprobieren, wie das ist.
Und weil ich einen Anwendungszweck dafür habe
auf der Arbeit.
Gibt es...
Gibt es Abkürzung für Log?
Ah, nice.
Log. Test.
Test.
Geht das jetzt so? Macht der das jetzt?
Natürlich nett.
Also, ich meine...
Wer könnte ja auch
damit rechnen, dass in JavaScript
ein HTTP-Get
auf diese Url
jetzt etwa den Text
der Seite anzeigt?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das ist das Ergebnis von JavaScript.
Das ist ein JavaScript-Objekt,
was ich zurückkriege und gibt's da drin
irgendwie einen Body oder sowas wenigstens.
Stimmt!
Ja, er ist die Buri, hat recht. Das ist
wahrscheinlich asynchron, alles.
Deswegen...
Ich will das aber gar nicht asynchron machen. Gibt's da nicht eine synchrone
Variante davon?
Weil ich kann eh nicht weitermachen.
Also, ich kann nicht weitermachen,
wenn ich das nicht hab.
Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit auch nichts machen.
So sieht's aus wie
Body oder so.
Okay, wir haben jetzt das Beispiel hier.
Okay, du brauchst eine Funktion, die dann
den, den, den...
...
What?
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Also, also, also.
Okay, okay.
Das probier ich jetzt mal aus.
...
Wir machen das wieder hier unten und die Ausgaben machen wir mal
wieder links hin.
Und ein bisschen kleiner, dass ich was sehe.
Die Sidebar brauchen wir eigentlich überhaupt nicht.
So.
Okay.
...
Die Schrift ist ein bisschen groß.
wieder zu
ane die abschließende klammer fehlt
haha
es funktioniert
abcrasht
weil also weil test not das ist richtig
das klappt
so exit code ist jetzt mal irgendwas mit 200 erwarten
warum ist der exit code sowas hier
voll, ach nee im moment status code brauch ich ja auch
nicht x nicht riss
hallo ausführen please
hat funktioniert
hat funktioniert okay exit code 200
das ist geil an typescript dass du für dieses für dieses normalerweise
antypisiert javascript zeug jetzt sagen jetzt hätte aus body gibt es noch was wie body
das gibt es natürlich nicht das das wäre jetzt ja auch viel zu simpel
ok ich krieg schon mal ich krieg schon mal den exit code wie kann ich denn jetzt
wie kann ich jetzt den inhalt lesen
komplizierter könnte man es nicht machen ich weiß auch die leute javascript flame aber
komplizierter könnte ich das ja auch in rust programmieren das ist ähnlich kompliziert gewesen
moment das ist irgendwas eventbasiertes
eventbasiertes
nein Patrick das ist nicht einfach content das wäre viel zu einfach
kannst du nicht dort net core nehmen doch das war meine erste idee dort net core zu nehmen
aber dort net core krieg ich nicht komplett
self contained hin es hat immer noch ein paar abhängigkeiten
ok das heißt ich muss hier dieses komische
ich muss das
ich muss das selbst
ich muss mir das selbst zusammenbauen
ich meine ich habe an sich keine schmerzen mit dass es geht
ja das ist schön wenn das ein stream ist aber ich will das doch einfach nur benutzen
ich will jetzt ja keine high super performance geschichten machen oder es nicht woanders hin stream ich will einfach nur den text
was die node.js standard standard lib ist ziemlich lauter vielleicht merkst grad
am einfachsten ist eine library zu nutzen wie axios
axios kenne ich das habe ich schon mal verwendet das kenne ich
sagt mir sogar was das ist saubel das hat das hat auf github irgendwie 9000
sterne oder so
ok sorry 35000 knapp vorbei ist auch daneben
was ist das für eine Linux distribution das ist manjaro Linux das ist ein arch
lilox mit besseren installer axios axios kenne ich und ich habe sogar gesehen das hat das hat
schon typescript sachen dabei und sowas
ja easy so so genau so was will ich das haben so so war so einfach
ok ganz nahe ttp scheiß weg ach so ja jetzt muss ich erstmal installieren
ja npm install axios
axios includes typescript definition
ach so geht es funktioniert anscheinend
also irgendwas ist an meinem node setup noch fehlen das merke ich daran dass ich
mein editor neu starten muss dass ich überhaupt dass er dass er mir erkennt
dass ich module installiert habe da stimmt was nicht das muss ich mir nur mal
angucken das muss ich jetzt machen
ja so ist das nice das gefällt mir axios geht so und da machen wir jetzt quasi
dass das gleiche was mir auch gemacht haben
mal den da
also ich habe das compile nicht gestartet ok das ist schon mal ohne fehler
und da kommt da jetzt ein string zurück
ok
es geht im prinzip scheint das glaube ich gewesen zu sein
bis halt macht man das überhaupt noch mit war ich habe jetzt total oft lett gelesen
und sowas was der unterschied ist war war es glaube ich glaube das locus glaube
oder wie ist das
mal so ein javascript bros
ok es funktioniert fast
am moment moment ob wir können jetzt den richtig krassen sie scharp style
machen
oder auch nicht fast fast habe gedacht funktioniert vielleicht
ok
ok das muss man das muss man das muss man in einer function machen ok das warum
auch immer aber es leuchtet zumindest noch so halbwegs ein
halbwegs ein
ja gut das ist ja in sie schab auch so dass er weht nur in assink geht das
leuchtet ein deswegen sind sie jetzt auch alle so happy dass man assink main
machen kann in sie schab
ok mal angenommen ich möchte das ohne ohne await machen dann sage ich jetzt
hier get denn musste brauche ich dann immer noch so eine so eine komische
funktion die aufgerufen wenn es fertig ist
ich will jetzt erst mal gucken wie macht man das jetzt wie ruft man als einfach
den inhalter seite ab
ok ja ok man muss man muss so eine so eine geschichte machen anscheinend
es ist ja nicht so wild
zweites beispiel von oben
ja so was die macht einfach punkt punkt denn und dann schreibt er ja das das
leuchtet ein das leuchtet ein dass man das so machen muss dann brauchen wir
dieses result auch net
sondern so
ja
funktioniert
das ist schick
so jetzt kann ich das doch bestimmt pasen
response
das jetzt wenigstens direkt text zurück
kann ich das nicht direkt pasen
warum nicht
response data mit zu haben das kann gut sein dass ich das will
nein das will ich nicht
was habe ich beckte tauchen watt oder ist oder ist data schon
jason moment ist data schon jason gepasst
kann das sein ist das schon
also also kann ich jetzt quasi fast so geht so was hat das so was
das
stimmt ich will ich könnte noch setzen
ja ich den typ von data sieht man nicht das ist natürlich auch ganz dolle
das ist bestimmt viel einfacher als ich mir das jetzt vorstelle
da stand noch was hat man automatic transforms for jason data
jason die folgt okay data ist schon jason also jetzt kann ich mir das erste
element ausgeben funktioniert dass das ja einfach ist viel einfacher als ich mir
das vorgestellt habe
ich kann es wahrscheinlich einfach sagen response data
gibt es dann sowas wie type oder so stark oder status status ist 200 status text
aber dann ist ok sondern hätte das müsste ich jetzt ja sehen was es für
den typ ist die content type oder sowas content type oder so was
content type application jason ja ja genau so ist das doch das doch sehr
schick gut das ist das was ich haben will
gut das ist das was ich haben will
mr freige ich auf leeren magen so eine frage jetzt zu beantworten da muss ich
mir echt mal ein bisschen näher gedanken drüber machen aber da kann ich
bei einem der nächsten streams darauf eingehen das ist so so dieb wieder
diskussion jetzt muss ich mal ein bisschen gedanken drüber machen
dass ich schreibe mir dazu was auch da kann ich in dem nächsten stream was
zu erzählen
ich bin auf nüchtern wagen bin ich gerade so kreativ mir da gedanken drüber zu
machen
ok was ist ein sehr gutes cms für das erstellen seiner eigenen internetseite
keine ahnung
habe ich nicht wirklich viel mit zu tun und ich wusste ich zum glück ich ich
wusste mich früher mal ein paar WordPress sachen kümmern also rein
betriebssystem seitlich hat jemand anderes gekümmert war ich auch sehr froh drum
was ich empfehlen kann doch mir fällt mir fällt eine empfehlung ein was ich
empfehlen kann ist ein statischer ist ein seitengenerator kein cms also cms in
form von WordPress wo du quasi online irgendwas verwalten kannst nehmen die
statischen seitengenerator wo du dann quasi lokal deine sachen erstellt lässt
die seiten durch diesen generator laufen letztes dann hoch das hat den riesen
vorteil also je nachdem was du wie viel dynamische sachen was du mit der seite
machen willst das hat den riesen vorteil es ist absolut null anfänglich gegen
jeden fall die sicherheitsglocken wenn du quasi alles was du haben willst bei
dir lokal generierst mit mit diesem zu einem seitengenerator wie heißt da
gibt es den pyson ganz bekannten ich weiß kommen gerade nicht darauf wie der
heißt
gibt es ein paar
falls es überhaupt so hieß das zeug überhaupt so ich glaube der hier ist
relativ bekannt
ja also muss du nicht mal schlaumachen in der richtung das ist wirklich
praktisch da erstellt so einfach lokal die seiten wie du es haben willst lässt
es durch den generator laufen und dann kommen statische seiten am ende raus die
letzte hoch das hat einen riesen vorteil genau check ist das der meinte ich aber
es gibt noch mehr gab es hier irgendwie ghost oder sowas
ghost block oder irgendwie sowas
ne das war was anderes des wobei das doch auch sowas das war doch auch was was
statisches seiten generiert wenn ich da jetzt nicht komplett falsch liege
keine ahnung musste ich mal stau machen es ist auf jeden fall echt praktisch du
hast überhaupt keine sicherheitsprobleme bei wordpress hätte
ich immer die bedenken dass da irgendwas nicht richtig funktioniert und leute
ok graus ist sowas wie wordpress
ne dann dann ist mist was ich erzähle da weiß das nicht statt ich hatte
irgendwie hatte ich das im hinterkopf noch ich muss mal gucken was es da an der
sachen gibt so statische seiten generatoren das ist super wenn du was
kleines machen willst ist ganz toll und selbst allgemein wenn du was alleine
machen willst mit hauptsächlich statisch im content also im back end wohlgemerkt
ne das javascript kannst du immer noch dolle dinger machen dann hast du nicht
das problem dass du da anfällig wärst für irgendwelche pp wordpress sonst was
sicherheitsflücken sondern das statische seiten mit ein bisschen javascript
drauf da kann dir nichts passieren auf serverseite
ei den oder wahrscheinlich einfach nur bei denn und das ist weil es damals cool
war einfach ist darum zu haben sagt würde mich mal über ein i3 setup video
von dir freund ich benutze die drei jetzt schon seit ein paar jahren auch mit
gut aber so richtig nett sieht es leider nicht aus bei mir wir haben diese vm
hier haben wir zusammen in einem live stream eingerichtet zusammen
installiert zusammen mit reinstalliert und die starr konfix drauf gemacht da ist
nicht viel dran angepasst
muss man musste mal gucken in den in den wats ob es diesen diese aufzeichnung
noch gibt wenn es die nicht mehr gibt fällt mir jetzt auch nichts ein wir haben
nicht viel dran gemacht also werden wir installiert ein paar
farbschämen und ein paar konfig datei drauf gezogen
er sebaro kenne ich mittlerweile würde ich allerdings eher auf dotnet course
setzen anstatt auf mono mono wünsche nur verwenden wenn ich cross platform
irgendwelche gui sachen in sich abmachen wenn und selbst dann würde ich eher
gucken dass ich entweder den gui teil mit cute mach da muss halt mal sauber
abfüllen plus plus beißen oder ne browser gui machen elektron oder sowas
oder gucke dass aber lohnt ja irgendwann mal was taugt was ja auf dort net core
funktioniert
ok so jetzt kann ich eigentlich das probieren was ich die ganze zeit probieren
wollte daraus jetzt mal mit diesem komischen tool was ich da gefunden habe
eine anwendung zusammen basteln die komplett self content ist quasi um es
mal jetzt mit windows ausdrücken zu sagen eine einfache exe wobei das darf
von unterdienung nicht sagen so ich habe jetzt gucken wir uns mal wie das
compile javascript aussieht hässlich wie die nacht sieht aus aber es hat javascript
vor allem transpilte javascript die noch mal nur mal schlimmer aus als echter
javascript sie baron wie hast du so schnell mein stream da hochgeladen wtf
wer hast du das so schnell gemacht ist ja krass so unterhosen treu frag kannst
mal kurz erklären was ich genau tue was du genau tust also wir haben paar
container aufgesetzt am anfang und jetzt probiere ich gerade ein bisschen habe
ich gerade ein bisschen type script ausprobiert so billig zeugs nichts
großartiges ist ja oder vielleicht weiß ich bin ich so der große javascript pro
und jetzt versuche ich daraus eine einzelne anwendung zu packagen lassen
mit diesem tool was ich hier gefunden habe weil ich habe da nämlich anwendung
zweck für ich habe auf der arbeit ein tool programmiert vor eineinhalb jahren
oder so das ist das lull tool das heißt wirklich so das habe ich so genannt
weil ich das lustig fand und irgendwie auf der arbeit kaum einer weiß was was
damit gemeint ist und es habe ich in der programmier sprache geschrieben auf die
ich absolut kein bock mehr habe deswegen will ich das jetzt neu machen in einer
anderen sprache ich habe zwar auch nicht großartig bock auf javascript aber ich
kann mit javascript wenigstens wahrscheinlich das will ich jetzt
ausprobieren anwendung basteln die alles enthält was sie braucht und einfach auf
jedem linux auf jedem windows läuft was ich mit rust auch konnte das alte
programm war ein rust programmiert da konnte ich auch mit 4,5 mb
selbst selbst content executable bauen was auf jedem linux lief die no gs
anwendung wird jetzt ein bisschen größer sein gehe ich mal von aus dafür kann ich
in no gs kann ich den javascript machen es ist zwar nicht so dass ich ultra bock
auf javascript hätte aber ich habe gar keinen bock auf rust rust ist nicht
schlecht kann man also das witzige ist es liegt rust ist nicht eine sprache wo ich
sagen würde die ist scheiße so wie javascript rust ist eine sprache die ist
sehr die versucht dich zu recht die ganze zeit zu nerven
das ist das konzept hinter rust rust versucht sich die ganze zeit zu nerven
und die ganze zeit zu sagen wenn du irgendwas unsicheres machst und ihr
könnt euch nicht vorstellen man macht permanent was unsicheres
rust ist gut rust ist eine super sprache aber für so einfache für so simple
anwendungen nach dem motto hier lass mal von ein paar seiten was abrufen und
generiere daraus eine konsolen ausgabe ist es einfach zu unbeständlich da
versuche ich jetzt mal ich beiße jetzt auch in abfüllen und basteln den no gs
anwendung packt die zusammen und gut ist bringt es an die leute weil ich gerade
sehe ich krieg hier krieg hier ein paar follows normalerweise ich mache öfters
mal programmier streams oder irgendwelche linux streams oder sonst was aber ich
mache so ich würde sagen in letzter zeit was eher so 50 50 also so 50 50
prozent irgendwas programmieren linux technik kram und 50 prozent
irgendwelche gaming geschichten also nur dass ihr das wisst ich mache nicht nur
programmier kram und hauptsächlich bin ich auch gar nicht auf twitch aktiv
sondern auf youtube twitch ist für mich eigentlich eher komplett entspannung
deswegen habe ich hier auch ich kündige die sachen nirgendswo großartig an ich
habe mich auch noch null um effigien sub oder irgendwas gekümmert ein brauche
netz ich macht es hier wirklich komplett zur entspannung ok package
wie funktioniert jetzt npm install package das ist einfach das kriege ich
hin ganz wichtig wir müssen und geht kommen mit machen
ich gehe mal davon aus dass man das da wahrscheinlich nicht adden sollte in
gittner wie es gut das sollte man wahrscheinlich
nicht enden dann habe ich keinen bock mit githex kluz zu machen machen wir
einfach mal et ts ts konfig brauche das ja das brauche wahrscheinlich auch geht
kommet ich kann einmal schreiben aminus m ok zahmer committed zwar nicht wirklich
notwendig gewesen aber gehört sich so so npm install package
haben wir ok pkg entry file ja gut entry feil ok wir sind wir sind wir sind die
option von diesem von diesem toll hallo mausrad please ok also ja einfach
einfach die datei angeben ok das ist einfach mein ges guckt und das finde ich
halt das ist das ist geil an dem ding deswegen wollte ich das auch mal
ausprobieren der baut hier standardmäßig jetzt die
anwendung zusammen als singelfile selfcontained executable für linux für
merck und für windows das heißt wir haben jetzt für alle gängigen ich gehe
mal davon aus wie bsd und so kann er auch ja bsd linux mac windows für arm
platform für x86 x86 x64 also alles was man braucht und man hat jetzt quasi für
jedes betriebssystem was man so braucht unsere super dolle anwendung die im
endeffekt eine seite abrufen was ausgibt so probieren wir mal aus ob das
funktioniert main linux beim geht nice so main mac os werden wir wahrscheinlich
nicht ausführen können falsches format und windows werden wir auch nicht
ausführen können weil er weil halt nicht linux format aber das ist gut das
richtig krass dass das funktioniert das ist echt geil
das ist genau das was ich brauch so und wie groß ist der kram denn jetzt im
ende im endeffekt 430 mb ich meine es ist schon ich meine es ist schon viel wenn
man sich überlegt dass die anwendung im endeffekt nichts macht ja allerdings
wenn man sich überlegt dass dann eine komplette node js runtime drin steckt
dafür geht es eigentlich wieder
so wie groß ist die die wie groß die anderen sind windows anwendung ist die
kleinste leuchtet auch irgendwo ein bei windows kann man sich wohl am meisten
drauf verlassen dass gewisse sachen einfach vorhanden sind weil sie bei
jeder wenn es in windows installation da sind und nicht 3000 verschiedene sachen
gibt ok ich würde sagen
also wir sehen jetzt schon mal dass es funktioniert unter linux das ist schon
mal ganz toll jetzt probieren wir das erst mal bevor wir es unter windows
ausprobieren probieren wir es noch mal unter anderen linux distributionen aus
also wir wissen jetzt dass es unter dem aktuellen arch linux funktioniert das
ganze so wie komme ich gleich per ssh da drauf gar nicht
wie kopiere ich jetzt überhaupt was auf meine meine container kann ich kann ich
mich auf den host ssh connecten
ach so ich kann mich nicht ich kann mich nicht ssh connecten weil ich
schlicht und ergreifend kein ssh installiert habe
ich habe wahrscheinlich einfach kein ssh laufen
nehmen wir das mal aus ja ja oops fack warum darf man da nicht auf
rauszugreifen sie nehmen es war im container
ja wie heißt das ssh package unter wir machen es erst mal unter im ubuntu
container da weiß ich wie man ssh installiert ist schon installiert ok
system ctl start sshd das müsste eigentlich funktionieren wenn ich kann es ja auch anpingen
geht doch geht doch habe ich kein account hier drauf
es müsste doch eigentlich auch in die andere richtung gehen also quasi ach nee
ha ich weiß warum es dann funktioniert hat was ist mein host das da ja ja geht
doch easy easy clap kann ich mich jetzt hier nämlich einfach auf mein host
verbinden als test mit meinem highly secure password und kann es mir rüber
kopieren scp das ganze liegt unter repos keine
auch noch verfolgt stream wo liegt da kram main linux main linux achso ja ok
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert main linux bäm das ist so
geil dass das einfach klappt sehr nice sehr nice gefällt mir ok und ubuntu
funktioniert der schritt schon mal wir kopieren uns jetzt kappen das scp
dass er jedes mal wieder machen muss ok das probieren wir das ganze jetzt mal
unter unter cento s aus das ist ein uralt cento s6 das ist steinalt
was ich habe mir das falsche kopiert
was ist denn habe ich was übersehen
man geht leute ist ich mal aufhören wie schnell das geht oder unter dem uralt
cento s6 läuft es mit abstand am schnellsten ich weiß nicht genau warum
ach nee ich glaube das aber einfach nur schnell geantwortet wenn du willst kann
ich die stream seit september 2017 als archivseite aufbereiten mit titel und
embedded stream auf welcher seite jetzt auf twitch oder stimmt theoretisch
könnte man den krempel als wort auf twitch wieder zur verfügung stellen oder
irgendwo anders das mache ich mir mal gedanken drüber sehen warum so ok auf
cento es funktioniert auch das ist geil das ist echt geil
so das probiert immer mal den letzten test beginn mal für dora system drauf
und kopieren uns das gleiche gucken ob es funktioniert aber wenn es unter dem
uralt cento es funktioniert hat jetzt auch funktionen fuck ok es fehlt
irgendeine wahrscheinlich ziemlich standard lip die wahrscheinlich so
ziemlich überall drauf ist bloß auf irgendeinem fedora nicht was natürlich
ziemlich räudig ist wenn das sogar auf dem cento s6 funktioniert aber was man
daran schön sieht ist es hat sich jetzt gelohnt dass wir uns vorher angeguckt
haben wie man ein paar container macht zum testen weil ich mein der hauptzweck der
ganzen sache ist ja dass es auf unterschiedlichen betriebssystem läuft
und jetzt wissen schon mal so tut es unter fedora nicht wahrscheinlich muss
ich jetzt einfach nur irgendwie den krempel hier installieren unter fedora
und gut ist ach nee ist ja nicht was der dnf jetzt wir sind hier unter fedora bestanden ah version version 7
deswegen geht das ganze nicht der will version 6 allerdings die haben version 7
das war übrigens einer der gründe falls derjenige von ganz am anfang noch da
ist warum ich keine dynamisch gelingte z plus plus anwendung machen wollte
wegen genau solchen dinger
jetzt funktioniert es war das dann war das in den back vorhin oder weil ich
mein es ist version 7 was auch immer oder war die einfach nicht installiert die
einfach nicht drauf fedora hat standardmäßig keine z plus plus standard
library drauf das habe ich auch nicht gesehen aber es hat sehr rohr sogar cento
s hat es drauf fuk
na gut wenn es den fedora ist mit irgendwas mehr als als standard
installation dann ist das auch dort drauf
definitiv so und jetzt kommt der große knackpunkt meint ihr es funktioniert
auch unter windows ich meine ich habe hier meine windows exe
warum ich keinen fein manager drauf
ich brauche mal einen fein manager dass ich ordentlich treppen trocken kann
meint ihr es funktioniert unter wendels
jetzt gleich sehen so nein ich habe keine feinbar tools
warum ich keine feinbar tools mitf
ich habe obs kaputt gemacht ich hab es zerstört ich habe obs da drauf
trecken tropft ich denke auch dass es ohne probleme funktioniert ich muss es
erst mal auf windows drauf kriegen wir können es bei windows einfach per ssh
hier drauf verbinden hallo ach ja if konfig gibt es ja nicht mehr ip
ich habe doch hier irgendwo dann da haben wir noch eine ordentliche windows
schälen da zahlt sich mal wieder aus ordentliche windows schälen zu haben
es hat gerade geleckt war anscheinend zu advance dass ich die jetzt aufgemacht
habe ich kann auch nicht copy paste zwischen der vm und meinem windows da
habe ich noch irgendwas nicht installiert vor ender tools mäßig dass
das nicht funktioniert näher vor ender tools an sich habe ich in seien es
wird es resize nicht richtig funktionieren aber irgendwas habe ich
vergessen muss man nicht in so eine hässliche gtk library muss man nicht
so eine hässliche gtk library installieren dass
musste glaube ich in so das kann ich mir beim vom letzten stream noch dran
erinnern man muss die so eine ganz ganz fragwürdige
gtk dings gedöns version installieren dass es funktioniert
es gibt kein installer das sind die open format tools die sind einfach da
funktioniert wenn man alles richtig installiert hat man musste aber wie was
waren das noch war ich kann mich da noch in einem der streams dran erinnern man
musste so mit man musste so eine doofe was nirgendwo stand was war auch erst nach
fünf stunden raus gekriegt haben das letzte mal in so eine komische gtk
library ist installieren ist das irgendwie so
ja was haben wir die haben wir installiert ok die haben wir installiert
kann es sein dass es einfach nur rumpackt
ich weiß es nicht mehr ist auch egal wir kopieren das jetzt mal per ssh
das kunde ich mir als nächstes mal
installen will ich die vmware tools jetzt eigentlich wie gesagt es sind
nicht die normalen vmware tools die du wahrscheinlich kennst mit dem installer
und so das sind die aus dem paket manager ich kann es mal reinstall ich
glaube dass was bringt ich ich ssh mir das jetzt einfach rüber ich habe hier
was habe ich für eine ip gekriegt bei einer vm 167
so schnell unter den aus hier der windows defender da im hintergrund was
guckt test ja auch wenn aus konsole hat probleme damit
der mag die farben und zeug nicht ok scp von repos slash stream slash main
minus wenn exe ist das ding oder ja hat funktioniert so jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt ob das unter mir noch funktioniert jetzt probieren erst mal
hier drinnen auszuführen ob es funktioniert geht easy genau das was
brauche im endeffekt auf jedem system läuft das einzige wo es nicht gelaufen
ist ist auf einem absoluten mini installierten fedora wo engel 10 plus
plus standard library nicht dabei ist
damit kann ich aber leben ich meine die leute die bei uns fedora verwenden die
haben das als desktop betriebssystem und auf desktop fedora ist definitiv die
standard z plus plus leihung dabei aber 100 prozentig
vielleicht hat er sogar irgendwie was hier
das heißt lib std c plus plus muss er richtig rum machen
gucken ob die vielleicht sogar da irgendwas stehen haben auf die auf ihrer
seite das ist schon mal einer
geschrieben hat dass es bei manchem betriebssystem nicht funktioniert
aber da kann ich mit leben das ist dann nur wirklich fast überall drauf
ja das ist gut das funktioniert ja schick schick was will dieser komische
hydrated bot eigentlich den den habe ich nicht den habe ich nicht hier in weitert
wenn ich danach noch auf google sucht er auch noch in anderen channels rum
ja
Ich weiß nicht, wo der herkommt.
Ist das, ist das vielleicht irgendwas vom Nightbot oder so?
Oder hat es irgendeiner meiner Mods, der lustig,
wobei es hat doch eigentlich gar keiner Rechte,
wobei braucht man, wie läuft das eigentlich auf Twitch?
Braucht man irgendwelche Rechte, um Bots in den Channel zu holen oder wie funktioniert das?
Also ich mein, klar, beim Nightbot weiß ich, da musste ich das anklicken,
aber ich mein, theoretisch könnte jeder einen Bot programmieren, der will.
Ja, wenn man nach diesen Bots sucht, findet man auch viele, die sich drüber aufregen,
dass irgendwelche random Bots unterwegs sind.
Ja, das ist ja beknackt.
Piss dich, Alde.
Weg ist er.
Ja, ich muss sagen, das war doch relativ erfolgreich.
Das, was mich ein bisschen ärgert, ist, dass es auf dem Fedora standardmäßig nicht lief.
Allerdings, ich mein, man wird kein Fedora-System finden, wo die Standard-Lib fehlt.
Wir können es ja nochmal ausprobieren.
Wir machen Stop, Fedora, wir machen nochmal ein Fedora.
Wir haben nämlich vorher einen 26 angelegt.
Legen wir mal einen 27 an.
Gucken wir mal, wie es da ist.
Ich finde die eigentlich, finde ich echt schick, ne?
Am Ende vom Lilux-Einrichtungs-Stream haben wir das ja gemacht.
Ich finde die eigentlich leistlich hier oben.
Ich finde die extrem stylish, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Ich finde die extrem stylish.
Man sieht ja auch, die wird teilweise rot, wenn man CPU-Lust verursacht.
Also, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel irgendwie macht, keine Ahnung, hoch irgendwas nach BC,
ich habe BC nicht drauf, what?
What?
What face?
Da habe ich kein BC drauf, was muss ich?
So, aber wenn ich ein bisschen CPU-Auslastung generiere jetzt, dann sieht man auch, das verändert
sich sogar grafisch, das riecht geil.
Die E3-Config gibt es nicht auf GitHub, weil wir haben, wie gesagt, das haben wir alles
zusammen im Stream gemacht.
Hier ist nichts großartig custom.
Das Einzige, was wir gemacht haben, ist die Gaps zwischen den Fenstern angepasst auf
fünf Pixel.
Und ansonsten, das ist fast ein, das ist quasi eins zu eins die Standard-Config, bis auf,
dass ein Chrome am Anfang gestartet wird.
Es ist nichts dran im Endeffekt, das haben wir alles im Stream gemacht.
Ist das Bumblebee-Status, nein, das ist E3 Rust-Status.
Sebaro, was ist denn Fischer, Fischier, wie auch immer?
Was ist das für eine Uhr?
Ach ja, das probiere ich jetzt noch schnell, ob ich noch einen Fedora 27, ob das da ähnliche
Probleme gibt.
Wenn nicht, war das vielleicht einfach nur ein Bug.
Fedora Bash, ETC, Red Hat Release, E27, SCP, Scheiße, Leute, mal fragen, ob ihr öfters
mit Linux arbeitet.
Nervt es euch auch, dass es IF-Config nicht mal standardmäßig gibt?
Ich habe mir über Jahre so sehr angewöhnt, IF-Config einzugeben für die Netzware-Config,
vielleicht, damit ich das ganz schwierig nur noch abgewöhnen kann.
Das ist wirklich nervig, repo-stream-main-linux-punkt, okay, das ist ja anscheinend ein Bug in.
Fedora, keine Ahnung, 26, was wir installiert haben gewesen.
Deswegen sind Container eine richtig geile Sache.
Man kann einfach mal so ausprobieren, total schnell, wie läuft es unter anderem unter
andere Lieblingsbetriebssystemen.
Ich könnte einen IF-Config-Alias machen, oder, ich könnte auch einfach IF-Config installieren.
Ich weiß gar nicht, in welchem Paket das drin steckt.
Ja, genau, nettools-package.
Wenn ich das reinhau, habe ich schon wieder IF-Config, aber das ist ja nicht so, dass
es groß wäre, irgendwie 120kb oder so.
Guck, bam, IF-Config am Start.
Wie sieht man, wenn mit dnf noch was installiert ist, oder nicht?
Leute, ich muss jetzt gleich los, ich habe mega Hunger, das Essen steht die ganze Zeit
eh bei mir.
Wie kann ich mit dnf checken, dnf-search-status, ist das installiert, ich kann das einfach
machen.
Ok, scheint installiert zu sein, ja, ist eine gute Frage.
Das kann nicht euer Ernst sein, oder, also RPM-Paketverwaltung finde ich so übertrieben
umständlich.
Ok, anscheinend ist bei fedora 27 die C++-Status-Library dabei, und bei fedora 26 ist sie nicht dabei.
Tatsächlich, ok, auch gut fedora, aber kann ich mitleben, wenn es quasi nur bei einem
nacken fedora 26 Probleme gibt, sonst ist es überall läuft, wunderbar, passt, dg-easy.
So Leute, wollt ihr noch irgendwas Linux-technisches wissen, oder irgendwie was, was ich an Fragen
ergeben habe, dann können wir das jetzt noch kurz, guck mal, es wird sogar rot, wenn ich
das Ding voll auslaste, geil, oder, Poggers, man sieht sogar Upload und Download, guck
mal, wir machen jetzt mal einen Speedtest, wobei der kackt da, da kackt wahrscheinlich
der Stream jetzt ab, wir machen jetzt mal einen Speedtest, man sieht hier so richtig,
das hier oben aktualisiert sich sogar, bam, 10 m, down, gleich kommt der Upload-Test,
dann leckt der Stream, Achtung, Upload-Test, bam, 3 m, 4,4 m, stream leckt, so Stream hat
hoffentlich fertig geleckt, also das stimmt nicht so ganz, also wenn ich das jetzt ein
paar mal probieren würde, der Durchschnitt wäre irgendwie so 37 oder so, und irgendwie
paar 90, aber damit kann ich leben, ich weiß, dass es leckt, es war leckt mit Ankündigung,
jetzt kennst du das Linux-Programm, das rm-rf macht, ja, das ist ja langweilig, es hat mal
auf der Arbeit einer, das kann ich jetzt mal kurz zeigen, der hat sich irgendwo was copy
pasted, das war auch so was nach dem Motto rm, rm blah blah blah, slash blah blah blah,
slash blah blah blah, slash blah, und irgendwie war in dem Dokument, wo er das raus copy pasted
hat, ich mein, das kann auch nur bei den krassen Business-Leuten passieren, ja, dass man quasi
Shell-Befehle über den Tickets-System, über den PDF an andere Leute weiter schickt, die
es dann raus copy pasted und einfach Enter drücken, ist halt so, und da ist irgendwie,
irgendwie so war das glaube ich, und da ist dann hinter, weil hier in Zeilenumbruch war
alles in dem PDF, was er copy pasted hat, ein Leerzeichen gelandet, und da war halt ein
bisschen mehr, wahrscheinlich war es ja noch, wahrscheinlich war es noch so was, ne, so
und da hat er das System kaputt gemacht, weil er falsch copy pasted hat, gebated, ja, Serious
Max PDF und copy pasted, nicht nur PDF, es hat irgendjemand in der Shell, das quasi ausprobieren,
muss man sich mal vorstellen, ne, es hat jemand in der Shell ausprobiert, dann hat er das,
dann hat er das raus copy pasted, wahrscheinlich in, wahrscheinlich über Skype oder über
irgendwas anderes, ja, an irgendjemand, der dann ein PDF draus gemacht hat, das PDF wurde
an ein Ticket angehängt, und derjenige, der das bearbeitet hat, ist dann in das Ticket
rein, hat das PDF geöffnet, den Befehl aus dem PDF copy pasted, ihn sich nicht angeguckt
und Enter gedrückt, das ist schon sowas von Fail, der ganze Ablauf, da fällt mir eigentlich
nichts mehr dazu ein, jetzt könnte man sagen, wenn man so einfach gedacht, könnte man sagen,
der Typ, der Enter gedrückt hat, ist zwar ein Schuld, aber der Typ, der Enter gedrückt
hat, ist genauso dran schuld, wie alle anderen auf dem Weg dieser Kette auch, weil du kannst,
man kann sich nicht immer damit rausreden, der Typ, der Enter gedrückt hat, ist dran
schuld, weil der Typ, der Enter gedrückt hat, der gedrückt verdammt oft am Tag Enter,
und da kann auch mal was durchrutschen, das muss von vorne rein vermieden werden, dass
so ein Kacke, Kacke passiert, ja, dem einfach die Leute mal ein bisschen mitdenken.
Ja, das bezüglich Screen mit Handy abfotografieren hatten wir auch jemand, der hat das gerne
gemacht, der hat gerne, der hat gerne Screenshots von, von Hostnamen gemacht und hat sie dann
rumgeschickt und gesagt, dieser Server bitte blablabla, bis ihm dann, bis, bis ihr dann
mal irgendjemand ins Ticket kopiert hat, das hab ich gesehen, hat irgendjemand, da hat
ihn dann irgendjemand ins Ticket kopiert, halt mit dem Typ dahinter, irgendwie so, nee
im Moment nicht das, nicht das, One does not, das da, das ist ja der gleiche Typ, hat
ihm irgendjemand ins Ticket reinkopiert, so nach dem Motto, One does not simply copy paste
image oder irgendwie sowas, eigentlich total unlustig, ja, gebe ich zu, weil ich glaube,
das hatte, glaube ich nicht so ganz verstanden, wenn auf der Arbeit gemimt wird, weißt du,
du bist richtig, mich nervt es ein bisschen, muss ich sagen, dass ich, dass ich immer so
viel als erst programmieren kann, beziehungsweise nicht mal, oder, weil sie können schon, aber
es grad nicht muss, beziehungsweise selbst nur noch so wenig im Vergleich zu früher
technische Sachen macht, sowas wie, was wir heute hier gemacht haben, ist zum Beispiel,
das geht mir auf der Arbeit ein bisschen auf den Keks, das mach ich nämlich ehrlich gesagt
am liebsten, so irgendwelche anderen Sachen ist jetzt gar nicht so, wenn du dir quasi
um eine Zeile, die du tippst, mehr Gedanken machen musst, als um was du da tippst, dann
bestimmt irgendwas nett, eigentlich sollte man sich doch hauptsächlich Gedanken drüber
machen, dass man da was Gutes, sich was Gutes ausdenkt und nicht noch riesen Aufwand drum
herum, klingt nach meinem Büro, ja, das ist glaube ich überall so, überall bei den krassen
Business-Läden ist das so, wo halt dann krass Business gemacht wird, nach irgendwelchen
Qualitäts-Standards und Dingern, die ja an sich nicht schlecht sind, sagt ja keiner dafür,
sagt ja keiner, dass sowas unsinnig wäre, es wäre manchmal nur von Vorteil, dass ich
jetzt auch schon öfters beobachtet, dass das eben nicht passiert, es wäre manchmal
nur von Vorteil, wenn man, wenn man sich solche komischen Abläufe ausdenkt, beim Ausdenken
die Leute fragt, die sie am Ende machen müssen, das hätte seine Vorteile, dann ist es manchmal
auch nicht so komplett an der Realität vorbei, so ich muss mir mal aufschreiben, was aufschreiben,
Video, warte mal, so Leute, ich werde jetzt mein Abendessen futtern, wir sind fertig,
hat eigentlich gut funktioniert heute, ISO 9000 fragt mich nicht, nach welchem Standard
da irgendwas gemacht wird, wir haben öfters mal irgendwelche super krassen Qualitäts-Best-Practice-Consultant-Typen da, die sich
geil finden, und da kommt dann auch immer irgendwas raus, und am Ende wird es dann trotzdem
nicht gemacht, obwohl dann auch die ein oder anderen sinnvollen Sachen dabei sind, da will
ich dann gar nichts gegen sagen, tja, gut, ich werde jetzt was futtern, ich hoffe euch
hat das Stream gefallen, ich meine im Prinzip, außer dass auf Fedora nicht richtig lief,
auf dem Fedora 26, war das sehr erfolgreich, ich glaube ich werde mein neues Lul-Tool nicht
mehr in Rust, sondern in JavaScript, TypeScript auf Node.js Basis programmieren, so, also
Leute, machts gut, bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss.